salut tout salut à tous
bienvenue pour cette troisième journée
de championnat du monde de de Fisher
random donc on a des appareils très
excitants aujourd'hui un Kevin oui bah
surtout bah il va falloir attendre
jusque tard hein parce que il y a moi
j'ai envie de revoir camsen et Nakamura
en duel puisque le premier match
aller-retour on s'était vraiment régalés
de la super première partie qu'on avait
adoré tous les deux à la grosse gamme de
Carlsen à la fin alors qu'il était en
train de dominer quand même Naka voilà
et bien sûr bah il y a tous les autres
matchs mais c'est vrai que on regardera
ça avec attention au deuxième partie de
de soirée et là on peut peut-être donner
les appareils de la poularde il y aura
un mini match entre sceaux et le joueur
local gretharson qui marque plus
beaucoup de points il avait réussi à
sauver une nulle contre sceau en tout
début de tournois mais depuis il se fait
bien ramasser et contre un bout à Torah
n'hésitez pas loin de créer la surprise
il a eu il a fait des parties
intéressantes mais à chaque fois
bah il s'est fait embrouiller parce que
les mecs sont super malin même si sur
une super partie le joueur local qui est
grand maître mais petit grand maître
surtout face à ces joueurs de l'élite
mondiale
le truc c'est qu'il se fait toujours
embrouiller même quand ils sont une
bonne partie donc il faut qu'il sorte
une bonne partie et qu'après il arrive à
tenir le choc c'est vraiment pas évident
et toujours dans cette poule ah souffre
on aura un époque contre eux
dans dans le match des leaders de la
poule quoi s'ils font
ça risque d'être extrêmement dur pour
pour rester sourds ce serait le même
assez logique qu'il fasse nul c'est ça
bah en fait je crois qu'un match nul
lui assure la qualification
et une époque m'a tenu aussi lui assure
une presque qualification aussi parce
qu'il restera à jouer Greta rsson voilà
donc donc bon tu vois
du coup je pense que cette partie enfin
ce petit match risque de pas trop être
mouvementé mais après
bon je suis pas si clair parce que au
final
au final bon
sont quand même d'humeur à combative en
tout cas ces deux joueurs sont très
compatibles durant tout le tournoi je
crois qu'on a assisté il y a eu une
seule partie dont je me souviens entre
nakafe et d'ocaf où on pouvait se
demander s'ils avaient pas mis le pied
sur le frein pour la jouer sinon je
crois tout a été vraiment encore c'est
pure spéculation de ma part sinon c'est
hyper pratique comme tournoi mais
d'ailleurs le sujet
des chasse 960 on est perdu au bout de
bah prête à ce que ça soit le combat et
la bagarre quoi c'est ça c'est ça donc
donc bon en tout cas c'est ça reste à
voir il y a encore deux parties à faire
je crois que ceux du restent à jouer
derrière
[Musique]
il faudrait que déjà qu'il gagne demain
et
donc du coup
il serait assez ouais on va voir mais
bon on en saura plus après cette ronde
là
et dans la poubelle il y aura un match
hyper intéressant c'est le match entre
fedo CF et Carlsen puisque
Hikaru joue contre blueba mais blueba
mais est quand même bien détaché avec un
0 à 0 pointé même si il a été bon hier
contre contre Carlson il a failli failli
faire quelque chose il était pas loin de
nul et nuls finalement il a fait nul
cellules et du coup ben il a perdu tous
ces mini matchs il y a pas trop de
raison qu'il inquiète Nakamura on verra
c'est un joueur de de grand talent quand
même blue boom mais il est il est en
dessous des joueurs qui sont présents
très clairement ces résultats indiquent
et par contre fais de CF ben si le bas
m'amuse bah il est encore en course
enfin même plus qu'en course le bas en
tout cas c'est toujours un peu chaud
même en cas de même en cas de nul ça
reste ça reste intéressant pour lui il
pourrait rejoindre après ils vont
s'affronter donc on va parler c'est
quand même pas si simple quoi pour pour
Carlsen il faut qu'il assure son premier
match pour aller jouer Hikaru serein il
en a besoin très clairement parce qu'il
voudra se venger un petit peu de la
gaffe il va pas vouloir en refaire une
autre ça va être assez intéressant à
suivre
je vous ai mis le classement pour
l'instant de chaque groupe donc on
voyait bien sûr que dans le dans le
groupe B 45 Nakamura ils ont 6 tous les
deux fais aussi F4 la victoire du
minimax apporte deux points donc là
c'est car ça nous fait gaffe donc 4
victoires rattrape rattrape regarde ça
derrière qui peuvent mettre la caméra
donc c'est chaud donc la Carlsen doit
essayer je pense de de serrer le vis et
essayer de
ne pas perdre quoi c'est hyper c'est
hyper important pour lui pour pour la
suite de championnat parce que bah il
veut être champion du monde
ça reste la 960 les joueurs vont être
assez assez intéressés à l'idée de
d'avoir un titre supplémentaire et
mondiale dans chaque sport et
t'intéresser de tout gagner quoi donc
particulièrement Carlson qui est numéro
1 pour le comparer à des
c'est un mix de Federer Nadal au tennis
quoi donc du coup il veut tout gagner
hein c'est le
la même chose et salut salut thé vert
et le thé vert salut Aurélie alors les
chaises sont de l'avantage à deux jours
oui quand même les blancs on a vu hier
que les Blancs étaient quand même
vraiment avantageux en début de partie
avoir les blancs déjà échec de base
c'est à ce niveau là c'est pas mal mais
alors surtout surtout
en ascendant c'est l'initiative qui
prime vraiment sur surtout et avoir les
blancs commencer la partie en premier
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important quoi on a vu tout au long
tout au long des premières parties et sa
souffra avec les Noirs directement
d'autant plus que le petit laps de temps
qui est donné aux joueurs avec leur
second nom juste avant les matchs donc
ils ont à peu près 15 minutes pour
préparer
les les deux rencontres aller-retour
my bosse les ouvertures à l'ancienne
avec un échiquier regarde les idées
surtout pour bien démarrer en termes de
structure de pions hier on a bien tripé
d'ailleurs avec stouf sur ce sujet avec
ben voilà les vous avez vu un bout de
coup on essaie de voir quel était déjà
le premier pion à bouger c'est souvent
en lien soit avec une sortie de pièces
de longue portée soit la valorisation
des caves à Limal placées vraiment c'est
ce qui ressort donc
[Musique]
le b4a5 de quincen qui vraiment tu vois
on a parlé de l'idée on avait dit B4 B5
blanc noir là et du coup sur
sur je passe une souverain il y avait
déjà avec B4 je me rappelle très très
bien je peux remontrer mais en fait la
partie d'hier je sais pas si elle est
encore présente de 45 contre blueba en
fait
ça devait être celle-là en fait hier on
avait cette idée en fait de base 4 pour
ouvrir le fou pour ouvrir aussi la dame
et on avait dit que B5 est un coin
intéressant pour faire la même chose et
que du coup toi tu as réglé de faire A4
qui empêche B5 pour au prochain coup je
B4 et avoir cette idée encore de
d'espace de centre à ce niveau là et des
pièces qui s'activent
et du coup ce qui s'est passé que C4 a
été on va dire le coup qui était le plus
joué le plus populaire bien sûr ce qui
est logique
et ce qui est marrant c'est dans cette
partie et ben sur ces quatre car c'est
un jeu A5 pour empêcher B4 donc en terme
de compréhension c'est juste quelque
chose d'assez incroyable parce qu'on a
vu plein de fois c'est 5 B4 surprendre à
me prendre on a eu beaucoup de position
là avec du coup un petit problème sur la
structure avec l'avantage au centre des
blancs etc et donc assez intéressant et
de voir ici à 5 ça montre quand même à
quel point le joueur comprend les échec
et je crois que c'est fait d'océf qui
avait joué A4 aussi stouf derrière dans
dans les parties en premier coup il me
semble qu'il y avait un 4 il est
vraiment le couper
tu vois c'est le délirant enfin je veux
dire c'est marrant et il cherche les
coups de structure
va jouer à 4 ici contre
la meilleure réponse moi c'était C5 il y
a eu des cinq donc ça veut dire que je
dois faire encore des programmes en 960
mais ça ira intéressant
donc mais bon après c'est une autre
histoire et thé vert qu'est-ce qui
pourrait griser une partie pour les
Noirs dans une partie s'endort un peu
moins pour les blancs où ça fait déjà
trop je trouve que c'est trop je dirais
un tiers de pions ou
un demi pion allez un ouais un tiers de
pion 0,33 je pense l'avantage blanc à
peu près c'est d'accord sauf je sais pas
c'est à peu près ça davantage quand même
ce mec de troisième alors ça il est
arrivé en drame hier je sais pas si vous
avez vu il se fait matin en un coup du
couloir en pensant qu'il pouvait faire
le rock mais vous savez qu'aux échecs on
n'aura pas sur échec quand on achète
c'est juste impossible et là les règles
sont un peu bizarre c'est un jeu quand
même qui n'est pas qui n'est pas encore
avec ça tous les jours
que 3e de sa poule alors qu'il est
champion du monde entier mais tous les
autres joueurs présents peuvent
quasiment gagner à l'exception de blueba
et Greta Arson qui était déjà beaucoup
plus faible sur la grille de départ
ça arrive très rarement quand je vois à
moins de 2700 puisse détrôner l'élite
mondiale c'est quasiment du jamais vu
j'avais juste vu une fois dans un
tournoi rapide corrobof mais qui est
souvent à la porte de 2700 très proche
qui avait une fois battu
toutes les lignes mondiales dans un
tournoi
mais du coup c'est c'est quand même
compliqué et Aurel donc du coup tu n'as
pas assisté mon setapé vraiment des fous
rires avec stouf pour les histoires de
rock donc on peut croquer en 960 oui tu
vas roquer sur les cases de d'habitude
donc ton roi G1 et ta tour en F1 ton
Rouen C1 et ta tour en D1 comme d'hab
par contre bien sûr là tu vas avoir une
position aberrante au niveau de ton roi
et ta tour et de l'autre tour et du coup
tu vas faire un grand grand rock un tout
petit petit rock tu vas bien voir il
faut juste les cases tu veux amener là
la bonne exemple tiens
ça va être la position sauf
c'est le tirage au sort c'est ça ça y
est alors ça c'est la partie
en fait dans une partie si tu veux voilà
ouais c'est plus simple parce que
expliquer de façon abstraite on voit à
peu près l'idée déjà on doit arriver à
une position classique du rock je vais
arriver à trouver l'Europe alors ici par
exemple
les blancs peuvent faire le petit Ranc
au grand rock donc là le roi était assez
au centre en fait mais le roi est pas
toujours au centre alors pour ok bon
rock c'est facile et pour aucun petit
rock là et ben je rock et ça fait comme
ça
bien et en fait pour rocker pendant
cette position là je termine la position
de départ
il faut bouger toutes les pièces
qui se trouve sur les cases ou au milieu
des cases dans lesquelles je leur ok par
exemple le grand rock vous savez que le
roi va ici et la tour va ici
mais pour faire il faut que je Roque
avec cette tour là d'accord voilà et du
coup
la seule pièce qui me gêne en fait au
final c'est la tour D1 qui est placé sur
la case de la tour B qui viendra en D1
d'accord donc par exemple si je joue le
pion des et qu'après je bouge ma tour au
prochain coup je pourrais rocker
c'est encore un bug je crois
quand même parce que alors on a eu ce
bug hier déjà
naturel au final tu as très bien compris
il faut que l'espace soit libre
forcément
[Musique]
mais si tu as une dame en H1 tu peux
trouver une config croisé un tour Eiffel
voilà tu as pas de bols hier j'ai buggé
aussi ça me faisait pareil mais ici on a
droit de roquet et par contre pour le
petit rock c'est un peu plus technique
c'est que le petit rock il se fait que
le roi là et la tour ici donc en fait il
faut juste que je vire les pièces qui se
trouve sur ces cases là et parce qu'on
au milieu par exemple bah je bouge le
cavalier je sors un fou
elle gêne pas pour l'Europe
donc là on peut croquer en fait le roi
ira en géant et la tour ira en F1 et
c'est normal donc en fait souvent le
rock on a une partie hier marrante je
crois que c'était saut qui a qui a roqué
très très tardivement dans sa partie
c'était laquelle
sauf qu'on trouve une époque peut-être
et pour elle c'est pas possible le roi
est forcément entre les deux tours donc
le Roi peut pas être en a un et la tour
en H1 le Roi peut être en B1 la tour en
A1 et la tour en H1 et ça ferait un rock
aberrant comme tu le dis il y a une
partie
ça va très bien
le petit emote mais non on peut on peut
pas ok lorsqu'on a échec petite rêve de
Volovitch stuff
bah ouais bon bah du coup bah ça c'est
un troll donc oui la partie la partie
dépôt ça c'était hier il y a eu échec au
roi un match du couloir enfin c'est pas
un mat mais une pièce devant pour pour
pas formater mais madame mon cavalier je
vais bien sûr tout manger bien du
couloir et en fait ici sauf penser qu'il
pouvait qui pouvait roquet mettre la
tour devant avec l'Europe qui en fait le
rock c'est un coup de légal dans cette
position je peux ok
que son roi était déjà sur sa case de
départ
ouais mais bon explication hyper bizarre
mais enfin oui mais bon là je peux pas
ok parce que je suis en échec dans les
vrais moi moi je comprends pas ce qu'il
a voulu faire aux échecs et ben si on
est en échec je peux pas Roger dans les
échecs classiques d'accord bah là c'est
pareil c'est en échec qui pouvait pas ok
donc du coup il a complètement halluciné
donc il s'est laissé mater en pensant
qu'il avait il pouvait faire partir faut
savoir s'il perroquet là il est pas mal
hein il y avait une belle position
honnêtement je pense que j'ai une
meilleure compréhension des règles d'une
960 que le champion du monde actuel et
ça ça me fait déjà bien plaisir tout et
toi aussi toi aussi tu as fait d'énormes
progrès maintenant tu connais mieux les
règles que le champion du monde actuels
quand on était hors stream hors stream
le premier jour et ben j'étais quand
même demandé comment on fait pour OK et
je suis devenu un bel expert tu veux
toujours maintenant
de devenir expert mais tu savais que tu
allais me raser sur les pronos donc
c'est pas tant que ça finalement
en fait sur le long terme tu m'as
fidélisé
donc ça c'est un jour ça c'est un match
où nepo doit essayer de ne pas perdre ce
match pour se qualifier
pour l'instant et nepo joue la calife il
y a aussi ceux qui doivent absolument
gagner et espérer que des peaux perdent
dans ce groupe là
les personnes il faut qu'il y ait une
partie c'est un truc bizarre je crois
que c'est il est pas content
qui va jouer
ouais c'est le fameux coup d'envoi enfin
ouais le fameux coup chez comment comme
au foot quoi la version chicane en fait
venir un sponsor ou un officiel et on
lui fait jouer le premier coup c'est ça
donc là on voit fédé aussi qui joue G4
ça me rappelle je sais pas si tu as vu
la vidéo de Kevin Bordy qui est qui a
joué G4 contre 452 qui a fait nul
ouais c'est c'est donc sa fameuse grobe
mais là c'est
une grotte qui est vraiment bonne alors
les cadences Aurel c'est 25 + 5 donc
c'est on appelle ça du semi-rapais du
semi-rapide donc qu'est-ce qu'on appelle
un incrément de 5 secondes c'est à dire
qu'on rajoute 5 secondes par coup et 25
minutes chacun autrement et au 30e coup
tu as 5 minutes en plus pour que les
joueurs puissent finir à peu près
proprement là-bas voilà donc 25 + 5 ça
fait une demi-heure chacun plus 5
secondes ça fait des parties d'environ
une heure une heure 15 à chaque fois
c'est ça il y a peu de théories
d'ouverture bah il y en a aucune
en fait parce que
il bosse mais 960 de position se fait
beaucoup surtout pour un jeu qui est pas
encore hyper populaire qui le deviendra
peut-être d'ailleurs contre on commence
à comprendre certains principes de jeu
les
commandes les prises d'espace sur les
ailes la valorisation des pièces de
longue portée assez rapidement tu vois
que G4 avec avec damasha qui peut sortir
et le fait de pas laisser le cavalier au
bord aussi toute la partie donc il sera
valorisé rapidement on peut estimer
maintenant que les rois devraient rester
plutôt sur le réel voilà actuel encore
qu'on a vu qu'un scène justement changer
d'elle avec son roi c'est très créatif
il faut faire attention aux courroques
non pas par rapport à l'égalité du coup
sauf mais c'est vrai que ça peut changer
concrètement une position quoi et des
fois on peut l'oublier en fait
tu peux rocker très très tard si tu as
pas bougé les pièces et
et c'est vrai que c'est assez marrant
est-ce que les ordis s'affrontent H24
j'en sais rien je pense pas
mais bon l'ordinateur de son il est
juste injouable parce que du coup nous à
la limite on connaît plein de théories
on peut des fois enfin plus maintenant
mais lutter contre l'ordinateur mais
surtout on connaît bien quoi dans le
début quand tu as travaillé les
positions et tout il y a il y a des
possibilités mais maintenant bah en test
random tu as juste aucune chance quoi
impossible
et il pourrait se préparer arcane les
joueurs avec des modules etc mais ils
vont pas le faire enfin ils jouent une
compétition de cinq jours dans l'année
très très important la notion de centre
et de valorisation des pièces mineures
dès l'ouverture et très très importantes
d'ailleurs tu vois un cavalier un fou de
sortie dans la partie entre fedocef et
Magnus avec Magnus qui tape qui tape
vite un pion adverse en fait c'est tout
bête mais vous savez j'aime bien dire ça
le développement piquant les coups
piquants ben c'est la prise initiative
dont nous parler stuff tout à l'heure
c'est la base
est-ce que je peux jouer au 3 ici du
coup
ça me paraît être le coup
de la partie moi j'aime bien H5 alors ça
me paraît bizarre mais tu vois l'idée en
fait de ces pièces là enfin de mes coups
c'est si en fait de
d'attaquer rapidement
les blancs et de gagner un peu de
l'initiative et G5
j'imaginais peut-être un jour que cette
diagonale peut-être un fou en
G6 peut-être une dame tu vois l'idée
d'essayer d'attaquer un petit peu
ça paraît pas très malin avec toutes les
trois mais c'est vrai nous dit qu'il est
déçu par un costume de fedos soyave un
peu trop tradi parce que hier il avait
un costume damier voilà pour faire
honneur à sa discipline préférée
qui est possible ah oui arcane aucune
chance pour un GM au 960 ça va être
pierre il va être la force de calcul de
l'ordi dans l'ouverture va être hyper
hyper intéressante et ça va être très
dur pour le joueur humain d'être précis
on a vu assez rapidement délai de 3e 4e
coup des imprécisions dans les parties
précédentes avec avec l'ordi donc
vraiment c'est plutôt un avantage pour
l'ordi parce que le calcul va aider même
s'il y a pas les bases de données les
joueurs eux aussi sont perdus même s'ils
ont la compréhension franchement c'est
trop créatif il faut vraiment regarder
des fois tous les possibilités on a vu
ces fédosef qui a placé un très joli X5
sauf si je dis pas de bêtises hier
et donc Nakamura très vite il s'est
retrouvé mal après il y a une partie etc
mais il avait oublié quoi et pourtant on
sait que Nakamura c'est un des joueurs
les plus créatifs du circuit donc c'est
vraiment c'est ça qui est top d'ailleurs
c'est ça qu'on a vraiment apprécié avec
depuis le départ franchement a commenté
je sais pas si on prend pas encore plus
de plaisir que dans des parties normales
parce que très vite on peut réfléchir la
position alors qu'avant il y a tout la
bataille théorique d'habitude dans les
positions et là on réfléchit par
nous-mêmes très rapidement c'est ça le
fait de te reconnaître la théorie aux
échecs bah ok ça reste intéressant parce
que c'est quand même bien de commencer
avec des notions etc mais là le fait
d'être perdu dès le premier coup en fait
je trouve ça génial parce que tu es dans
la jungle dès le début et
bah il faut réfléchir par toi même pas
avec tes connaissances tout ça je trouve
ça vraiment génial quoi en tout cas
comme je l'ai dit
avant de commenter ce champ avec toi et
ben j'étais toujours un peu sceptique
par rapport à cette variante du végétale
je trouve que c'est intéressant mais bon
sans plus mais depuis que j'analyse avec
toi tous les jours et ben je trouve ça
hyper fascinant en fait et
ben je conseille hyper intéressant en
fait juste j'adore
c'est super bien c'est super bien pour
répondre à la question de Volvic ils ont
15 minutes avant un minimum un minimat
on va dire que c'est deux parties donc
aller-retour pour pas voir les blancs
dans chacune des positions que chaque
joueur est blanc et du coup ils ont 15
minutes pour se préparer avec leur
secondant sur le sujet et
ils font bien le PAF d'ailleurs c'est
assez marrant hein du coup c'est fait
boucler le le centre là avec une un
avantage d'espace pour les pour les pour
les blancs côté et le roi
donc on peut imaginer peut-être plus
tard alors je sais pas si c'est possible
mais un C4 il y a mon roi derrière
certes mais je peux encore faire le
petit rock toujours en peinture encore
une fois c'est dangereux un jeu de bossé
GF mais si la position est fermée je
peux toujours garder
l'avantage d'espace
H5 qui était
donc tu as pas le choix
et après j'ai vu que tu avais mis la vue
grand échiquier les joueurs tu préfères
après bah c'est comme vous préférez hein
pour les zaynautes
après là j'avoue je t'avoue que j'avais
oublié de l'enlever donc je vais mettre
au début quand les gens arrivent et puis
à la fin pour le diagnotte c'est parfait
ça voilà donc du coup donc là vous voyez
plus la position c'est mieux c'est de
faire des pour montrer un petit peu et
on voit les noms des joueurs je pense
que l'ordi il est il est parfaitement
tellement bien maintenant j'espère que
ça te convient en tout cas vous nous
dites vous pouvez nous demander d'aller
voir certaines parties ouais n'hésitez
pas à nous poser vos questions en fait
sur le sujet comme vous l'avez fait
depuis le départ et nous demander aussi
certaines des petits souvent on garde
les parties de Carlsen on aime beaucoup
avec stouf on est un petit peu pareil
par rapport à ça
on aime la simplicité
dégagée par le jeu de manuscrit à des
résultats incroyables mais
ce qu'on trouve tous les deux hyper
sympa on est tous les deux assez fans
c'est que c'est parti sont tout à fait
compréhensibles quoi ça boit le numéro 1
mondial ça boit de le genre qui bat tout
le monde parce qu'il fait c'est pas
facile à faire mais c'est tout à fait
compréhensible par contre quand il le
fait ouais clairement et qu'un scène
depuis le début on a adoré un peu c'est
vraiment ses débuts et donc moi je vois
bien qu'à ça ne fait rien quand une fois
je parlais si c'est intéressant l'idée
de contrôler la classe de 5 et de faire
passer un jour le fou sur le casque
blanche comme ça donc avaler B6 ok donc
on sait pas encore une personne va ok
moi je pense secrètement que personne va
rentrer là-bas
ça serait vraiment par impossible
maintenant que la structure est figée
parce qu'ici du coup voilà on a figé la
structure le gras pas l'attaque a priori
il m'a donné beaucoup de casques
après tout dépend de la volonté de faire
F6 en cas de cavaliers E5 quoi c'est
toujours pareil si tu veux faire F6
toujours pas petit rock normalement
parce que moi c'est quand même pas mal
ouvert
féliciter pour la régie
et Zuma Zuma alors là c'est une question
qu'on a beaucoup à l'Europe donc le roi
est toujours entre les deux tours c'est
une obligation et tu rock sur les cases
initiales c'est à dire les cases j'ai un
F1 pour le petit rock et c'est un D1
pour le grand rock c'est à dire les
cases de d'habitude en fait
donc le petit rock est matérialisé là en
bleu par partout et ça a été mis et le
grand rock en fait une fois que la tour
D1 se barre on peut faire tourber un
saute-mouton du roi qui fait ça et que
je bouge moins
ça j'ai un bug mais normalement ici je
perroquet avec mon roi et la tour passe
en terre en fait le roi reste ici à 31
et sur pareil et pour le petit vent que
ça pourrait être pareil en fait dans
l'idée vous voyez en fait c'est plus
simple
et il se demande un peu ce qui se passe
et en fait il voit carrousel fait
dossehiev donc il se dit que le
placement de pièces bon ça doit être ça
doit quand même pas être si bête que ça
mais en fait ils sont en chasse 560 donc
là la position de départ était folle si
tu veux ce qui mot c'est justement les
échecs en théorie voilà
et ce genre d'initiative la populariser
cette version du jeu qui est très
intéressante les parties commencent
comme ça en fait du coup et du coup il y
a pas de théorie et
les ouvertures bah tu tu réfléchis avec
ton cerveau avec tes connaissances de
structure de pions etc de tout ça et tu
joues d'échecs donc pour ceux qui
demandent c'est une vraie variante du
jeu d'échec pour moi c'est à dire que
c'est pas une variante juste pour
s'amuser c'est pas le Bouftou par
exemple pour ceux qui connaissent ce
qu'on appelle le keepergan il faut
donner tous ces pièces non il y a beau
avoir quelques calculs à faire c'est
n'importe quoi il y a d'autres versions
on peut jouer au blitza 4 on peut
s'amuser si vous voulez avec plein de
variantes qui sont proposés d'ailleurs
sur le site chasse.com des variantes
très ludique mais là c'est une variante
très sérieuse si vous voulez le chasse à
160 on joue aux échecs c'est juste qu'il
n'y a pas la théorie habituelle donc ça
c'est top
ouais tout le championnat est en 960
on a vraiment huit joueurs de très très
haut niveau donc on a
cancerief on a aussi
Greta Sarson alors greterson c'est le
local de l'étape c'est pas c'est pas le
plus fort
Wesley
qui est le joueur local qui est pour
l'instant pas du tout ces matchs il a
fait match nul enfin une partie nul
contre le contrôle saut d'ailleurs voilà
c'est un aller-retour c'est blanc noir
donc il a fait nul avec je sais plus
avec les Noirs je crois la première
partie contre saut et après il a pas eu
toutes les parties mais c'est hyper dur
les joueurs c'est juste là vous avez un
joueur qui est très fort c'est un grand
maître qui joue contre les le top 10
mondial c'est ça
qui nous dit quelque chose
de très marrant et de perspicace c'est
les échecs en plus complexes en 1960
tout à fait
c'est marrant ce petit G3 encore de
Wesley
[Rires]
sur le pion
c'est c'est pas une franche réussite
l'ouverture des Noirs
[Musique]
mais
peut-être que c'était
ça c'est une sorte de après tu fais dame
là et petit rock et tu as une
tu as une sorte de scandinave oui oui
les fameuses structures carroca nous ce
scandinave 6 quand le fou en C8 c'est la
catastrophe là il n'a plus fou c'est
vite c'est pour ça Greta Sun c'est
permis de le donner c'est réputé solide
après là le placement des pièces c'est
un petit peu bizarre oui le fou G2 est
intéressant
qui me fait un petit peu
[Musique]
là
tu peux grand ok aussi non je crois pas
ah si je peux ah d'accord ok
merde si tu m'avais proposé un swap je
me disais je pouvais gagner le solitaire
facilement là encore tu dois passer par
un échec souffre
mais c'est vrai que c'est bizarre c'est
vrai que c'est bizarre parce que il
passe par les chèques normalement mais
là il passe pas par les chèques
est-ce que tu penses que Wesley SOS
gourre aussi ou pas bah là je pense que
ouais
ça serait quand même très drôle qu'il
fasse encore un coup illégal en deux
parties tu sais
chaque match il fait un coup les gars
attends je suis quand même prendre du
monde mec ça va quoi ce matin tranquille
et bien bien numéro un mondial ce qui
mot et
il contestation possible
effectivement une histoire
effectivement en ce moment mais ça ne
l'a pas destitué c'est à faire en cours
comme on dit mais il n'est pas destitué
de de son titre etc on peut on peut
perdre une partie de toute façon en
terme hello pour l'instant il n'y a pas
tout a été comptabilisé et il est
largement numéro un mondial voilà
il doit avoir encore une cinquantaine de
points de plus que le deuxième ce qui
est beaucoup
50 points enfin c'est gigantesque c'est
à ce niveau là à ce niveau là de suite
en fait en fait à un niveau amateur
c'est pas c'est pas si énorme que ça
mais
un niveau
établissement dit à 50 points hello
c'est juste énorme
déjà tu vois entre guillemets pour moi
50 points c'est ce qui me manque pour
être grand maître donc enfin c'est quand
même et je mesure la différence si tu
veux Stéphane de 50 points à l'eau bah
je les ai pas c'est dur quoi vraiment et
toi encore tu es
tu es coefficient 10 c'était mettre
international quoi tu vois si je te
prends par exemple un amateur à 1700
hello bien sûr ben ils ont certains le
coef40 en fait à ce niveau là les points
ils montent plus vite parce que tu tapes
plus de marge de progression en fait
tout à fait est-ce que je veux dire
c'est que déjà pour moi 50 points c'est
beaucoup donc pour les mecs comme
Carlsen et compagnie c'est énorme ici
quoi tu vois c'est vraiment la il y a
l'effet pyramidal moi on est nombreux en
haut plus c'est gains de points et l'eau
sont rendus extrêmement difficiles donc
réussir à la coller de 50 points à
toutes les lits mondiales bah c'est un
fossé gigantesque quoi qu'il a réussi à
à creuser voilà rappelons que Magnus
Canson est reconnu du meilleur hello de
tous les temps je crois que
virtuellement il est à 2889 il me semble
il me semble virtuellement 89 ce qui est
assez
40 en fait si tu veux quand tu gagnes
une partie par exemple qu'un scène quand
il gagne une partie contre un joueur de
son hello bon il en a pas un mais
admettons qu'il gagne un joueur qui a le
même loque lui et ben il caresse 5.0
parce que son coefficient c'est 10 en
fait
quand tu passes 2400 hello 2400 une
seule fois dans ta vie et ben ton
coefficient il passe 10 sinon
normalement tu es en coefficient 20 ce
qui veut dire que par exemple moi je
copie sur 20 par exemple je suis pas
encore 2400 hello et si moi je gagne pas
de coffre avant que mon élo je gagne 10
points
Kevin qui lui est coupé 110 va gagner la
moitié
des fois c'est bien parce que quand tu
fais un gros tournoi de merde et ben du
coup des fois je suis bien content
d'être quand même 10 tu vois pour que ça
amortisse un peu les défaites
voilà c'est ça
d'avoir un frein mais du coup l'idée en
fait c'est que tu veux ton calcul
attention matin au petit matin un coup
je pense qu'il va avoir je pense qu'il
va il y a pas de sens
il va jouer deux il va faire mal
comme il a voulu faire dans la partie
d'avant
bagarre pour répondre à la question de
Ahmed en fait le coefficient si tu veux
c'est on va dire la le
je sais pas comment l'expliquer mais ça
va être la valeur de calcul quoi
dès que tu passes 18 ans ou 2300 euros
bah tu passes que vous en vain et dès
que tu passes 2400 et l'eau tu pars ce
que fait sur 10 et 4 Arsène il est cofu
110 depuis qu'il est né
d'ailleurs on peut dire que il y a un
petit problème au niveau de la fixe ça
devrait être une qu'on dépasse
virtuellement 2300 Elo parce qu'il y a
des joueurs qui sont passés plus de 2500
parce qu'ils ont enchaîné les partis
pendant une période tu vois Stéphane et
du coup j'ai toujours au même coiffe 40
donc c'était jamais vu je me souviens
j'ai fait un tournoi à San Sebastien en
Espagne avec avec Sami robinside il y a
longtemps et il avait joué un indien qui
était maître feed et qui avait 2480
et il avait 16 ans 17 ans et maître
fille
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est que
OK et
Samuel a joué et en fait bon il a gagné
il a fait une bonne partie il a bien
joué mais en fait le joueur on a réalisé
sa Courbet l'eau si tu veux
et en fait il avait gagné 300 points ou
plus 400 points en un classement en
faisant même pas des pertes en fait si
tu veux il a il a joué à 2002 2300 hello
mais il avait un vélo tellement pas
qu'il est monté à quasiment 2500 et du
coup
il était hyper respecté on voyait il y
avait des grands mecs qui proposaient
nuls dans l'ouverture bah lui il accepte
à chaque fois mais sinon dès que tu
voulais jouer il perdez quoi
et là j'ai vu il y a pas très longtemps
qu'il est passé maître
mais il a perdu beaucoup de points hello
il a 2300
mais bon maintenant il a 2310 ou tu vois
il a perdu
donc il a fait non
mais bon après il serait passé maître
quand même hein mais bon après
bon tu as mais il y a pas mal de joueurs
des fois qui qui font des gros bien sûr
il y a pas mal de gens aussi qui sont
maîtres filles et qui ont 2100 hello
parce qu'en fait ils ont passé
virtuellement de l'espace avec le
coefficient 40 donc bon après ça c'est
autre chose et playbo salut à toi salut
philosophe aussi
[Musique]
il a une cinquantaine je pense ça tu
peux le voir sur le site de la feed tu
vois sur la feed et tu cherches tu peux
regarder pays au monde etc et tu as
toutes les stats donc le champion les
champions les plus fort c'est les Russes
ils ont
[Musique]
bref donc est-ce qu'on fait un petit
tour on a on s'est un petit peu garé là
on va aller voir dépôt
n'est pas qui est en
juste en mode pas perdre
[Musique]
dans cette partie qui joue j'ai 4 aussi
et qui répond au centre avec des 4
rapide
et lors de
differlo on est à peu près
80 je crois 80 points
[Musique]
66 66 46 à peu près 66 70
à peu près tout le temps autour de 24 50
voilà où je joue très peu quoi je joue
très peu et mes derniers tournois c'est
je perds 0,5 je perds d'eux je gagne un
voilà c'est donc c'est vraiment toujours
un petit peu la même chose et
du coup je me maintiens à 24 50 voilà et
et Stéphane a des variations déjà comme
il a expliqué un coefficient supérieur
donc il peut perdre pas mal mais aussi
gagner pas mal et la dernière fois lors
des des événements qu'on avait streamé
sur chasse comme fr il avait un petit
lot à 22,90 c'est là il a fait une
remontada au niveau de son hello puisque
tu es quasiment 23 je crois Stéphane il
y a pas longtemps j'étais à 2383 là
avant de jouer ma dernière partie et
j'ai perdu 17 points en une partie dont
on parlera pas d'autres parties qui
étaient ignoble mais je perds 17 points
sur une partie ça y est ça fait beaucoup
quand même donc j'ai perdu un joueur à
2100 quasiment à -17 quoi alors moi ça
doit être tu as perdu 17 sur une partie
donc le maximum que je peux perdre avec
mon coef10 c'est 8,5 si je fais si je
fais une merdouille mais si je bats 45
je gagne pas grand je frein je gagne pas
grand chose
et c'était quand même assez hypothique
l'histoire stouffe
et après pour le battre les deux sont
durs les deux sont durs
différence oui oui il y a des
différences puisque bon déjà c'est pas
les mêmes cadences si tu veux donc c'est
pas tout à fait comparable moi je dis le
vrai jeu c'est le lent quoi je joue sur
tscom en 3-0 je vais avoir un hello qui
est aussi entre 26 26 50 bon franchement
c'est je suis pas du tout à ce niveau là
je suis pas sûr d'être plus fort en 3-0
quand quand lent donc de toute façon les
sites en règle générale sont sont
généreux avec le hello des différents
joueurs c'est pour ça c'est logique mais
et chascom n'est pas le plus généreux
là-dessus mais mais elle est quand même
un petit peu
non mais en fait il y a des joueurs qui
sont plus
habitués que d'autres
dés le fait de jouer rapidement de tu
vois internet c'est quand même différent
donc on peut pas dire que vraiment il y
a une règle qui est valable pour tout le
monde
certains qui disaient qu'il y avait 300
points de plus ou 200 mais j'ai pas
d'accord parce qu'en fait au final ça
reste du Blitz ça reste des
jeux en fait c'est des parties là on
peut pas comparer des parties lentes et
du Blizz déjà de base donc mais quand
même j'ai l'impression que les sites
sont pour moi sont quand même plus
généreux c'est vrai que que bien sûr
enfin moi je suis comme toi j'ai à peu
près 2006 2007 sur james.com je pense
pas avoir tes Lola en vrai ça serait
[Musique]
qui sont plus forts que l'autre sur un
ordinateur moi je préfère par exemple je
suis vraiment plus à l'aise
moi aussi mais par exemple en histoire
de prime moi je suis un très mauvais
très mauvais quoi tu vois j'ai pas je
suis pas de l'école Bullet et du coup
par exemple moi j'étais plutôt bien mais
dans le moins de 30 secondes je suis à
signer quoi je suis vraiment je le sais
quoi tu vois si si j'étais meilleur
juste dans la phase où il reste 30
secondes ou 2 joueurs bah j'aurais un
plus gros vélo de chasse comme mais bon
c'est un indicateur
c'est du plaisir de jouer aux échecs en
ligne mais le vrai jeu ce qui fait de
Magnus qu'il est numéro 1 mondial c'est
son hello de classement lent et c'est du
coup ça qui est révélateur quoi parce
qu'il a il a moins de l'autre Maka en
sur internet qu'il est au fortnite
et c'est une classe au-dessus
tous les deux d'ailleurs même si Naka
pourrait faire une relais lyrique de
temps en temps non mais en fait ok il
est capable de faire de faire quelque
chose mais bon
après nacré il a choisi une autre voix
aussi maintenant il est plus dans le
streaming que dans le déchets hein donc
il le sait aussi il veut pas de champion
du monde d'accord
des blancs
qui est assez curieux parce qu'après F6
cavalier F7 il fait une fourchette mais
je le mange
et ce pion qui risque d'être perdu en
fait
tu veux pas comparer ça à l'exercice
parce que ok elle est partie hyper sur
Internet enfin encore une fois c'est
Internet où il perd les Indiens ils perd
tout ça c'est pas des parties ou
vraiment il est focus sur un vrai
chéquier championnat du monde on est
l'eau vous voyez sur Internet
c'est la détente quoi franchement ça n'a
rien à voir moi je comprends
l'investissement n'est pas le même
investissement
mais il va être sérieux il va quand même
vouloir gagner mais bon c'est c'est
quand même pas du tout la même chose et
encore une fois c'est le cadence rapide
c'est internet ça n'a absolument rien à
voir avec les vrais échecs donc voilà
pour moi ça c'est pas vraiment des des
vraiment des informations qui me qui
m'inquiète et cette creuser un petit peu
pour qu'on pour nous demander la
différence des joueurs à 1200 1600 2000
en rapide de 30 minutes ou différé sur
chasse.com donc des parties plutôt
fiables je pense que c'est le sens de
de sa demande à combien ils vont tourner
en moyenne comme elle au départ
je pense que oui on peut on peut déjà
enlever 100 points quelque chose comme
ça un minima quand même sans 1500 1900
peut-être et après peut-être tu peux
enlever 100 ou 200 mais après faut voir
puis il faut aller faire des tournois et
puis tu verras
comme il y a quelques années j'ai eu un
premier rôle à 1700 car j'ai battu
quelqu'un qui avait 1050 en particulier
pendant mes deux premières années j'ai
pas pu affronter l'adversaire plus fort
pourriez-vous me dire la raison
normalement ah oui tu as joué en club et
tu faisais des Interclubs donc enfin
j'imagine donc si tu joues en interclub
et que tu joues en division en division
4 par exemple on a 54 bah c'est
évidemment moins fort que la nationale
une généralement ça se passe comme ça il
aurait fallu que tu fasses des Open et
les open portent très bien leur nom
c'est ouvert à tous il y a des maîtres
qui sont là il y a des
il y a un maître et grand maître et
après il y a un effet pyramidal la
plus plus tu vas gagner de partie plus
tu vas jouer des joueurs forts en fait
et là tu aurais pu dans ce cas là jouer
vraiment
et tu vas pouvoir modérer la même chose
que tout à l'heure stouf
donc voilà et
regarde j'ai trouvé hyper intéressant ce
qu'il a fait à gaffe et là en fait on
voit que c'est un petit peu contre les
règles qu'on a vu depuis le début en
fait du random depuis qu'on commande
depuis 3 jours regarde ce qui s'est
passé en fait il a joué le coup G6
provoqué F6
blanche une fois qu'il a fait ça le pion
F7 va tomber ça c'est une évidence pas
le défendre bah je peux refaire dame là
mais bon il y a ton rêve 7 je vais
perdre le pion mais ce qui s'est passé
les deux pions on va on pourrait croire
au final que 45 perd un pion
mais en fait ce qui je panique mauvais
oups j'ai banni le mauvais merde je te
remercie de charpente
[Rires]
et en fait et en fait du coup
il y a un dû un comme qui a dû arriver
sur le chat et ça a du décaler je suis
désolé du coup j'ai paniqué j'arrive
même pas à voir qui j'ai banni en fait
Kanos il est revenu je pense je me suis
demandé pourquoi j'ai pris un ban le
chat je suis désolé
je voulais je voulais ben merci beaucoup
le charpentier
[Rires]
merci merci à toi tu as heureusement que
tu es là j'avais même pas vu c'est le
pauvre il est là
désolé
donc du coup je disais en fait et ben il
a mangé un pion à 45 mais qu'au final
regarde il va rester avec que des
mauvaises pièces le cavalier B1 qui est
pas encore sorti qui va se faire chasser
à chaque fois en plus qui va sortir le
fou des deux qui est carrément le
mauvais fou dans la position le faut de
la même couleur que les pions et les
blancs ils ont le bon fou un super
cavalier et du coup plus enfin
d'activité regarde il y a aussi le la
case E4 le pion arriéré en E3 il y a pas
mal de choses qui se passent et après
j'ai 6 à 4 je reprends la case du
cavalier le fameux il n'a jamais sorti
donc
c'est ça G5 donc il va essayer d'ouvrir
un peu la position pendant que le pièce
blanche ont du mal à sortir et tu vois
en fait j'ai l'impression que bon fais
dossiers on rappelle il est en mustwin
il doit gagner la partie il doit partir
c'est foutu il pourra pas se qualifier
en fait pour le pour le pour la finale
donc il doit prendre des risques donc il
a mangé un pion
par contre si tu veux
ces pièces quoi tu vois il préfère
manger un peu plutôt que que
de valoriser ces pièces
surprise prix j'aurais eu évident en
l'air ça fait beaucoup il y a H2 il y a
j'ai pas mal de problèmes tu vois
mal placé les cases blanches encore une
fois je vais roquer en plus ici là
j'arrive pas à le faire j'ai un problème
les gars j'ai un buzz j'ai un bug je
peux pas ok
mais rock elle a bien huit voilà et
après on va essayer de mettre les tours
ici manger aux trois et franchement
plutôt belle avantage pour les Noirs
j'ai l'impression j'ai un peu moins mais
j'ai très agréable plus d'espace et j'ai
super pièces alors c'est toujours pareil
parce que des fois on me demande on est
comment tu sais que le pion ça vaut le
coup de le donner vous regardez l'état
des pièces c'est à dire que c'est
toujours un petit peu abstrait j'ai
l'occasion de jouer plusieurs fois
contre Maxime vachelagrave et à chaque
fois qu'il sacrifie lui-même des fois
j'aimais bien l'analyse tu vois sauf
quand il disait je suis pas sûr quoi tu
vois mais ouais ils sont pas sûr mais
ils sentent que les pièces sont bien
passées et se gourde pas il y a du goût
pas souvent en fait donc du coup c'est
ça qui est intéressant à comprendre ça
reste abstrait ils peuvent pas
comptabiliser l'avantage concrètement
mais il semble que les pièces sont mieux
placées que le roi de l'adversaire est
faible que le roi est sain etc etc
[Musique]
l'activité des pièces plus important que
matériel ça c'est clair donc regardez
vraiment vos pièces voir ce que quels
sont votre possibilité et quels sont vos
objectifs aussi dans ma position et là
vous rendez compte que le roi blanc il
est hyper ouvert le roi noir aussi mais
les pièces blanches n'arrivent pas en
fait à attaquer la attaquer le roi alors
que là vous voyez sur le cadre avec un
des trous et voilà un grand rock alors
bien tout aussi l'arme mais il y a des
échec donc je suis pas sûr mais
peut-être que tout recettes à mes chats
qui roi B7 en fait le rock il est fait
parce que je pensais tout à l'heure
maintenant mais attention
BA4 qui peut ouvrir la colonne B et
ouvrir sur la voie peut-être juste
manger en premier et puis après même
prise de roi B7 je sais pas quelle
quelle est la fête nous dit c'est une
question d'activité de marge de manœuvre
en fait c'est ça veut dire comme ça et
gros bide ça lui à vous salut à vous
ouais
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait un petit tour
rapide
alors ça c'est le match Naka qui gagne
ce match il est qualifié d'office ça
c'est clair donc
bonne position
ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
donc on avait rien vu du tout je crois
c'est parti
en fait
je me suis rappelé de prise d'imprompt
et autant pour moi c'était ça et du coup
là c'était bon en tout cas ils ont la
même idée d'ouverture
et n'en fout des deux H4 donc ils vont
taper sur le pion h vous voyez on sort
les pièces donc c'est les mêmes
principes que dans le vrai jeu
donc
cavaliers
le tempo de plus au départ et grâce à ça
il domine et après ben les noirs sont un
peu plus mais du coup est-ce que je peux
manger sur échec et puis manger F4
on pouvait
prendre et prises ca va aller prendre
l'âge des fois et après je sais ce qui
peut tomber derrière vous voyez s'il
prend je prends en défendant là et
j'attaque aussi le pion H6 du coup à
l'air intéressant là
ça sent pas bon quand même
en plus encore une fois avant ce temps
salut Michel
salut Michel bah c'est surbooké c'est
bon signe tu dois avoir de l'activité
mais c'est toujours un plaisir de te
voir parmi nous en tant que grand
passionné
et je peux te dire que ça ça va te
plaire les chasses 960 si tu les as pas
encore vu
que souvent Michel ici signal s'il est
là et chess 960 on se régale avec tout
alors avant ce qui s'est passé dans la
partie on était allé un peu plus loin
donc je vous rappelle ce n'est pas qui
est
qui doit pas perdre en fait si il perd
ce match il se retrouve
à se faire attraper par perso on voit un
peu ce qui se passe donc il se laisse
prendre la
la fourchette
E4 c'est compliqué encore tout ça et
tout est en prise il y a tout qui est en
prise de partout
prise cavaliers
très calculatoire et très bordélique
donc
il perdait 4 là j'ai un gros centre
quand même des blancs
[Musique]
donc là encore une fois vous voyez il y
a plus non même pas il a un Pione parce
que là
le pion la majorité 3 2 des blancs elle
est fixée vous voyez le Pione on peut
jamais rien en faire et du coup le
cavalier F5 est un des boulonnable donc
là les noirs sont déjà presque gagnant
c'est un peu plus net même peut-être
plus ce qu'on a l'activité donc là il va
se faire
câbles les pièces bloque toute la
position
H5 C3 ouais ça commence à être chaud
d'Amadou
alors moi ça me fait peur quand il
attaque comme ça parce que quelques
Laurent hyper bien et depuis hier on a
vu que quand même rarement qui se
tromper dans ces calculs
donc
il veut manger à trois il y a le
présenter 4 échecs
il a répété une fois
et encore une fois si
je le connais c'est un petit canon à ça
et en plus c'est hyper bien comme
tournoi
et donc là ici en fait c'est
juste
fait match nul donc quand je dis match
nul c'est vraiment les deux parties et
ben il est qualifié d'office pour les
demi-finales du coup c'est parti
au moins match nul sur les deux parties
ça allait retour je vous rappelle et là
du coup c'est chaud quand même
français 3 maintenant auparavant il y
avait tout reprend B5
maintenant il y aura le matin c'est de
et du coup
ça menace demain aussi qui m'attendais
et ben
faut trouver un trou
10 minutes toujours des pots quoi qu'il
en soit il joue vite même quand il a des
fois une poubelle
alors juste pour répondre à l'exercice
malheureusement on ne pourra pas
s'exprimer
à ce sujet là sur la chaîne on nous a
dit pas en parler en fait
mais l'abandon abandon de dépôt il
abandonné
il a même pas un seul échec donc abstrav
qui a encore gagné ça fait 3 - 0 qu'il y
a des points depuis le début de
championnat et il est vraiment fou quoi
on peut déjà dire que
malgré les trois parties restantes
il reste finalement un millimètre plus
un demi minimat on peut dire qu'il a
gagné les poules
il a sur il a combien il a 7008
au moins match nul
il a 7 ans ça c'est la cinquième round
donc en fait il y a eu en 10 parties
mais du coup il a une meuf pour
l'instant 8 et demi sur 9 quand on est
top niveau c'est quand même pas mal bon
de l'amicate 0 à retard sonne il a mis
pendant 3-0 à dépôt et il a fait un une
sur deux pour l'instant contre contre
soi
ok donc du coup ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle un du jour pour à une époque
qui lui ben va devoir se refaire dans la
prochaine partie pour ne pas perdre ce
match sinon ce soir
on va aller voir ça d'ailleurs à voir ce
qui est ce qui se passe ce doit gagner
bien sûr
ce match pour avoir une chance de se
qualifier encore on était là d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure avec cet avantage
significatif perte de fou et bon roi
vous voyez que encore une fois on voit
cette pollution on se dit en fait que
c'est un peu chaud ce qui se passe sur
le bras blanc etc visuellement
visuellement c'était catastrophique
effectivement mais une fois que tu rock
en fait ah en fait ça va
ça va même hyper bien et le il est foutu
le roi noir il est là il est pas sorti
clairement Alex on a bien d'accord avec
toi on en a parlé tout à l'heure et on
trouvait que c'était c'était juste fou
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait j'ai tourné la
tête pour voir le commentaire d'Alex et
ça y est il a il a pas réussi à taper le
roi qu'est-ce qui s'est passé là
d'avoir un gros jeu sur le roi et il a
pas réussi à le ouais c'était ici je
crois
là je sais pas ce que propose
l'ordinateur encore une fois on est sur
son ordinateur
déjà
c'était peut-être possible wow il a
essayé de changer les pièces d'ouvrir
mais au final après
Darson il est revenu dans la partie avec
son
moi j'allais dire son prénom plus c'est
plus trop donc bon
final tenable mais bien sûr on dit que
dans ces positions il y a des pions sur
les deux ailes le Fou est supérieur le
fou pourquoi le Fou est une pièce de
longue portée donc il va plus vite du
nail à une autre maintenant ce genre de
position c'est assez technique puisque
ça dépend de l'activité du cavalier noir
et là cavalier intéressant donc c'est
une position qui est encore complexe
elle est partie en live à Tom nous on
les a hein là on est en live cette
position elle est en cours tu vois que
le temps des Noirs en train de s'écouler
si tu voulais si tu veux la regarder de
ton côté je t'invite à aller sur
chaise.com dans la section événement tu
vas trouver tu pourras suivre aussi en
même temps que nous si tu veux
non je crois que c'est toi politaino
c'est actif dans le monde des échecs ils
jouent tout donc
soit il est quand même hyperactif
il est marrant Alex il est temps vous
avez 100 balles à parier vous misez sur
nepoint pour le prochain Championnat du
Monde tu sais qu'on fait on fait pas mal
de Paris
armes du coup je parierai sur le dépôt
du coup pour te prendre que ça bah en
plus dépôt il a plus de d'expérience on
a déjà fait un mais ok
il est quand même je trouve que Ding est
plus fort en fait
je trouve qu'on est pas assez fort et je
trouve que
bien sûr il est exceptionnel mais je
pense qu'il avait été très mal payé lors
du dernier Championnat du Monde où il
s'est pris une raclée contre Magnus
alors que au départ tant qu'il n'avait
pas perdu cette partie en plus de 100 et
quelques coups 7h30 de jeu ce qu'il
faisait sur l'échiquier était très très
prometteur pour moi en tout cas dès
qu'il a perdu cette partie elle
s'écroulait
comme nous après voir moi moi ce qui est
pas un compliment
donc là d'accord qui déroule on voit il
va manger depuis le pion
h6400 mais très récemment elle a eu une
petite déconvenue voilà comment ça
attends juste une question il se passe
quoi sur
même la chose elle est pas contente
elle passe de coton gagnante ah perdant
en fait non mais c'est pas ça la partie
parce qu'il y aurait tout reprend la
fuite en un coup
donc il n'a pas pu jouer il n'a pas pu
jouer
une
bêtise de retransmission parce que les
trucs bizarres
[Rires]
maintenant OK et
qui va transformer ça sans problème de
faire du jeu de massacre voilà
c'est quand même la partie qui
nous faisait
la plus intéressante que la retrouve
elle est là
donc Carlsen fedoce qui doit gagner ce
minimum
je pense que c'est la partie ici est
perdue pour faire je pense que la
qualification déjà d'ailleurs
moi il va perdre
très très
facilement cette cette position enfin
Magnus ce genre de position
B1 pour défendre à deux caprices de
cavaliers c'est compliqué et en fait
dure mentalement cette position en
termes d'objectif mentalement c'est dur
même pas que mentalement la pollution
est juste mauvaise en fait je pense
c'est ça c'est la totale quoi c'est
difficile quand donc en plus quand on
carrassen qui est très précis cette
position elle est elle est très très
dure à tenir donc on va voir en tout cas
ça va se passer mais
plus élégant fait l'océf hier il a
marqué des points avec son costume
damier je sais pas si tu l'as vu mais
Alex mais c'était c'était du lourd il a
vendu du rêve
on croit bien a été joué
donc il veut bouger le cavalier quand
même
il est souvent comme ça
[Musique]
il avait un T-shirt assez basique relevé
je crois par Néandertal
et sinon c'est
en général il y a toujours des chemises
couleurs un peu extravagantes
un
[Musique]
dans ma chatte
je mange pour prendre Tour Eiffel
j'aimerais bien quoi justement je l'idée
je peux peut-être faire toi H3
je vais manger ah tu veux faire damage 7
dans ma chambre tu reprends ton H3
si je prends il y a match du couloir
donc tu as un problème quand même sur le
pion ici
et en plus je peux jouer faux recette à
tout moment
désagréable cette position aussi après
je suis pas obligé de faire de la
machette en plus tout de suite mais déjà
c'est
si je faisais la même comme ça en fait
avec Dame j'ai 7 ans
je commence à me plaisait est-ce que tu
es en train de faire et du coup c'était
qu'on arrive toutes les faire quoi en
fait j'ai pas fait exprès je voulais
venir manger trois en fait pour attaquer
le pion
les deux sont hyper fort en fait c'est
beaucoup mieux ça souffle ça va gagner
tout de suite ça c'est plus fort
la dame est plus forte en fait il y a
des menaces de maths en fait c'est
voilà
beaucoup beaucoup
bientôt une défaite pour fait doser
[Musique]
du monde pour cette c'est demi-finale et
finale de finale pour
Championnat du Monde
finalement la partie la plus
intéressante celle de gretharson
finalement contre Wesley Sow parce que
le reste je pense que bluebao va bientôt
perdre contre hikaro on peut pas assez
faire un petit détour juste pour voir
que louborn se fait ça fait bien finir
par les carreaux on les voit la caméra
ça ça a été abandon on voit 45 déjà
par va gagner on a vu que nepo a perdu
et du coup il ne reste sans avoir
[Musique]
qui sait arceau doit mettre la pression
absolument en catharsale forcément parce
que c'est le seul joueur qui n'arrive
pas à le battre
donc c'était un avantage
bon après il peut se faire Bacher ma ma
avec les Noirs mais bon là ça a l'air
d'être
ça a l'air d'être vraiment
vraiment pas mal pour greterson
est-ce qu'on prend le 4 dans cette dans
cette poésie il faut calculer quand même
qu'elle va dépendre à apprendre avec un
truc comme ça voilà parce qu'on va
pouvoir sans doute prendre le pion c'est
3 mais après faudrait pas laisser toutes
les lois parce qu'à ça aussi qu'on peut
calculer mais ça a l'air chaud tout ça
c'est hyper concurrent en fait ça c'est
pas une bonne idée quand même parce que
tu peux parler mais après
c'est pas clair mais ça doit faire nul
quand même je pense
et la prise
même par là en fait
je peux garder derrière la case faire B2
prendre le pion dans le meilleur
condition et puis aller chercher les
pions FGH on aura un pion à part un pion
B un pion extérieur donc il a joué
d'ailleurs
du coup lequel me défendre les 7
tours
mais après si je fais genre ça
et ça je percevrai chaque quand même
c'est vrai
donc
peut-être juste y a poussé si c'est
chaque ah non il y a tout B6 maintenant
n'importe quoi
peut-être que juste en fait il faut
jouer ça
ah oui et qu'en fait je te dis que tu
prends sur un échec je mets le roi là
un peu bizarre
et après essayer de voir mais ce que je
pourrais faire au moins c'est 5 en plus
après
et puis j'attaque ici et puis
ça commence à faire peur quand même pour
ça fait peur
bon on va voir
[Musique]
ordinateur parce que ça m'intéresse voir
ce qui fait l'air d'être plus logique
quand même
[Musique]
ultra logique de garder le cavalier en
dessinait que c'est quand même les noirs
qui poussent pour faire quelque chose
ici
ouais ça reste ça reste un temps mais
c'est vraiment intéressant et à la place
c'est intéressant aussi tu me dis ah
mais ça ah j'ai pas vu quelque chose
j'ai pas vu surtout le problème ça il y
a tout F6
[Musique]
mais bon
en pratique
revenir en arrière pour le placer
ok intéressant mais dans le cas là on
voit encore une fois que personne il a
38 secondes à la pendule et ça joue
beaucoup on est au 35e coups ce qui veut
dire qu'il a déjà eu l'incrément de 5
minutes et que du coup ça risque de
vraiment jouer en salle des rêveur cette
partie
ouais je pensais bien que c'était son
idée parce que j'avais pas vu le je
comprenais pas son coup kb5 mais oui
mais on s'est fait cette réflexion en
commentant on savait pas trop à quoi
s'attendre c'est la première fois qu'on
commente un événement 960 et on a pris
énormément de plaisir particulièrement
dans les ouvertures où c'est très
créatif très vite en fait parce que là
c'est des échecs maintenant mais pendant
les 15 premiers coups c'est de la folie
quoi ce qui peut ce qui peut survenir
surtout spécifiquement on a bien
apprécié les jeux de structure et ça
c'est vraiment intéressant en fait pour
étudier les structures d'option sauf si
jamais pensé le faire en tant que
entraîneur d'ailleurs moi qui aime bien
faire des exos un petit peu particuliers
des fois quand je peux pour changer un
petit peu casser la routine mais c'est
vrai que des exos liés aux structures de
pions un petit peu comme l'exemple que
tu as introduit tout à l'heure en début
de stream tu sais avec notre délire BK
c'était hyper intéressant en fait pour
expliquer les structures c'est clair
une technique qui est intéressante qui
est que quand on va faire mal au temps
tu vas assez prendre ton temps pour
enchaîner pour voir pour pouvoir
enchaîner plusieurs coups d'affilée à
tempo tu vois c'est vrai donc je pense
que là
manger mais après il va réfléchir à une
nouvelle position tandis que là je peux
commencer à regarder je vais faire
croire j'ai quand même derrière et le
pouvoir le faire réfléchir plus vite tu
vois donc ok salut c'est pas
complètement
il a amélioré il a fait roi roi crois
j'ai 4 et pas Roy F4 comme ça j'avais
dit avec la petite cavalier 2 qui était
échec et donc là il va y avoir du coup
une course un peu de pions le roi qui va
manger à h6 le purge
et le fou qui va sacrifier un moment
donné sur le pion C2 ouais mais je vais
essayer dans d'enlever cette possibilité
là je pense que c'est une des idées de
gretaarson ici quand il prend F2 roi C3
tu vas où
comment est-ce que je peux pas essayer
de vous montrer des bateaux par rapport
à cette
cette histoire de Manu cavalier devant
la pendule c'est pas facile ouais ouais
bien sûr bien sûr en fait il peut paumer
parce que même ça tu vois ça reste aussi
une possibilité tu vois je vais faire ça
prochain coup et essayer tu vois c'est
pas mais bon c'est des décisions qui
sont très dur à prendre
je vais prendre un F2 pour pas
où tu pourrais tu pourrais manger avec
deux pour pour assurer si tu veux tu vas
assurer
5 donc ceux qui veut garder soit tu veux
garder le pion et lui qui avait cavalier
si tu veux je crois que ça bouge pas mal
là
vu que ça a l'air de jouer de jouer
assez vite
car c'est qu'il faut trouve torse deux à
l'instant s'il prend j'ai du couloir
avec dans ma chambre assez éthique
heureusement parce que sinon bien sûr il
y avait les idées de pâtes surtout
reprend ses deux dames il y a dame C8
avec une dame folle là il y a presque 3D
d'ailleurs avec Dame là et on va prendre
à trois malheureusement ça n'a pas
donc
il faut préparer la cage du roi
OK
c'est toujours pas on est presque à
pouvoir jouer dans match 2 pour
contrôler les échecs
car celle qui a 20 secondes à la pendule
courage 2 il a joué
donc il est possible prise et roi B6
c'est en fait la pollution est trop tôt
il veut la finale de dames
sur tablette
mais malheureusement si cela
serait drôle mais ce matin
[Musique]
il a fait quoi
c'est comme le coup que je pense que qui
va être joué ici et qui a l'air assez
forcer l'investir parce que
ça peut possible un point 6
quoi que j'aurais peut-être dame ces
deux qui gagnent je crois ils ont un
petit peu ils ont répété une fois j'ai
l'impression
idée
prochainement jouer pour d'un match de
vraisemblablement et surtout ça qui peut
pas jouer d'un pseudo
[Musique]
il va gagner facile en fait
même contre Magnus
trop t'es trop de ressources tout le
temps
qui a peu de temps
voilà
7 ah il y a la température
qu'on avait vu aussi on avait vu l'idée
en fait
de nul vous voyez regarde ce qui s'est
passé
avec dams et deux bah en fait le roi il
est bloqué tout est bloqué chez les
Blancs donc on va se référer les deux
pièces pour faire pâtes donc
il avait déjà vu en jouant en jouant en
apprend à F6
mais comme un lion et il a réussi à
tirer
[Musique]
il a pas le temps que chercher mieux
il avait vu qu'il pouvait faire nul mais
mais bon ok alors les ordinateurs
parce qu'il avait il avait dominé toute
la partie mais il faut finir et il faut
finir pour pour tout le monde c'est bien
donc là il a raté
sauf que là du coup tu vas où parce que
la tour bloque dans le ouais parce que
après roi parce qu'en fait
là je vais en A6 pour plus que les
échecs parce que sur roi là il y aurait
échec là ou là d'ailleurs
et une fois que je fais tout recettes du
coup j'ai plus accès la case des villes
donc
je vais embêter
et du coup il y a plus
du monde de Blitz il a été champion du
monde il peut il peut il peut gagner
cette partie là mais si vous voulez avec
le temps en moins ce genre de choses
arrivent c'est beaucoup moins choquant
que le dame 4 contre contre ricaru ou là
il avait du temps pour pas se prendre de
bêtises comme ça voilà c'est totalement
fou ce qui s'est passé entre West Esso
et greterson visiblement ils ont réussi
à faire chacun donc un cavalier de plus
et donc je pense quand même l'avantage
attends je vais enlever le truc avantage
noir quand même
cette position parce qu'il y a quand
même des réseaux de maths peut-être un
cavalier
ça peut se faire perdre avec les deux
couleurs ce genre de position mais oui
ça a l'air d'être plus sympa à jouer
pour les blancs je vois pas comment
pourrait partir quand même bien sûr
c'est l'heure de parier est-ce que tu
veux parier pour que personne
il m'a coûté il m'a trop coûté
c'est à dire que si
[Musique]
vous gagnez je gagne rien quoi c'est
plus marrant quoi tu vois aussi
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
ça j'imagine il faisait dame 5 sauce
était forcément mieux que ça c'est pas
vrai il a fait dame 5 et normalement il
a fait un B8 bah celle-là était
échec
j'ai pas vu bah il avait il avait la
masse avec la dame 5 et d'un coup
bah c'est cool en tout cas moi je suis
content pour garçonne qui franchement
après hier il a perdu sa partie contre
il était complètement gagnant il est là
il fait son tournoi et il finit pas à
zéro et franchement ça fait plaisir
il y a plusieurs pour lui qui qui a un
tournoi très difficile et qui
franchement bah écoutez il se bat et là
il a gagné une partie quoi juste que
enfin pour vous c'est peut-être pas ouf
mais un grand maître qui a 25 30 qui
fait un tournoi avec Elite mondial c'est
le niveau de jeu enfin l'écart en fait
entre les joueurs et hallucinant et
il sait pas qualifié en plus c'est
vraiment
il y a trop d'écart quoi alors je prends
mon petit post-it
c'est pas vrai
je marque merci
toujours
trop facile
je vais vous montrer les résultats en
espérant qu'il soit actualisé ici
[Musique]
c'est pas encore actualisé
au moment où je décide d'aller je contre
lui et ouais c'est ça fait le matinait
tout de suite en plus vraiment c'est
clair on a eu 15 secondes de Paris c'est
quasiment le Paris le plus court qu'on a
eu
très très peu de temps alors que si on
avait pas regardé l'inverse je pense ça
réagit un peu plus longtemps sûrement
mieux
un Greta Swan j'ai bien compris qu'il
fallait que je m'en éloigne d'ailleurs
je vois du monde éloigner mais je
trouvais ça tellement tentant le parait
que tu m'as fait sauf que bon j'étais
obligé de relever quoi d'ailleurs je
pense bientôt tu iras faire un petit
tournoi et qui habite
et une déboîtera tu sais je dis ça c'est
pas vrai quoi
[Rires]
important tu vois histoire que ce soit
cagoule jusqu'au bout c'est ça bon en
tout cas nous on va partir pour une
petite plage de pub donc on se revoit
Après la Pub à environ 5 minutes donc là
il y aura la même position vous le savez
deuxième partie c'est les mêmes joueurs
les mêmes matchs couleur inversée et je
vous rappelle qu'après on va dire sous
le coup de aller 19h45 20h il y aura les
gros matchs avec Carlsen contre Nakamura
le remake donc on est impatient pour
tout ça
ça marche à tout de suite
allez à tout de suite bye bye
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a son est revenu
enfin je suis revenu avec la partie qui
qui a commencé on va aller voir Carlson
fedocef qui a commencé à l'instant
donc Kevin qui va arriver dans dans
quelques instants ne vous inquiétez pas
alors que s'est-il passé dans ce début
de
deux parties il y a eu un cas de la loi
de 45 des 5 doigt scandinaves
G3 ça c'est une idée qu'on a vu pas mal
dans le parti on a vu cette idée avec la
partie de
Nakamura dans la partie de de saut tout
à l'heure
donc après dès qu'on le cas d'un point
de 4 ici cavalier 6 et dame 2 donc on a
eu aussi ce thème là de revenir dans la
partie aussi de de je crois que c'était
chaud tout à l'heure avec jouer des
cadres et le contre un système à base de
structures scandinave
et karocane
donc E6 cavale F3 food et 6 et là on
peut s'attendre très sûrement à un coup
comme comme D4 qui va arriver je pense
très très vite
des cas peut-être cavalier G3 fou G2
salut Kévin qui est surprendre ça jamais
été aussi rapide quoi ben moi aussi je
me suis fait surprendre c'est pour ça
que je t'ai pas attendu en fait
généralement généralement ils sont ils
sont un peu plus lents que ça pour faire
pour
vraiment sereinement je pensais même pas
que tu étais là tu vois et là je vois
j'ai j'ai le direct et du coup c'était
assez marrant et je voyais je voyais
Néandertal qui qui se moquait qui est
pas de vacances en Islande pour la
famille terrier mais en plus c'est pas
c'est pas impossible cette histoire
j'aimerais bien aller en vacances en
Islande au contraire mais bon ça se fait
pas comme ça faut trouver un petit peu
de temps quoi
dans la partie d'avant avec un petit G3
tu vois pour revenir ils aiment bien
sortir leur dame ça ça marche bien et le
fou en G2 il est très bien placé voilà
donc ça c'est l'idée qu'on avait déjà vu
avant donc Karl scène qui pour assurer
la calife et s'il devrait gagner la
partie je pense même qu'un match nul
c'est pas mal quand même
à condition de ne pas perdre derrière et
que fait dossier afghan je crois ouais
c'est ça donc bon je t'encule
mais ces personnes parties ce serait un
peu la catastrophe
mais on va voir un peu ce qui se passe
blue web Nakamura a gagné la première
donc Nakamura a assuré sa calife avec la
partie d'avant même s'il perd il restait
très bien ça changera absolument rien
dans le tournoi par rapport à la poule
boom qui est qui est au fin fond du
classement et qui a tout perdu pour
l'instant donc cette partie on va quand
même la suivre parce qu'une partie
intéressante tout ça sans contre deux
super joueurs mais cette partie là ne va
pas du tout influencer la suite des
événements dans ce groupe
et salut à tous ceux qui nous ont
rejoints pas PNL chips
on devrait on devrait pas mal se régaler
après le raid de skybloz donc bienvenue
à vous en tout cas
qu'on soit faire oui merci à skybozy
mauvais moment quand il y avait la pub
c'est clair
j'ai trois et F3 F3 c'est plus con c'est
comment ça se fait qu'il était obligé de
jouer F3 et ça a été malin encore de la
part des Carouge j'imagine il a fait un
petit fou à 5 et alors Fouilleux ça
reste encore jouable j'imagine
prise et D5 pour figer la structure sur
la mauvaise couleur quelque chose comme
ça qu'il redoutait
pas voulu en fait après à après avoir
joué F5 le fou noir était pas forcément
très bon donc il faut deux il y a
peut-être un échange aussi étoureux 8
pour gagner du temps voilà toujours
pareil mais on voit G6 en tout cas vous
voyez un l'obligation de sortir les
mauvaises pièces la dame coincée dans le
coin le cavalier coincé dans le coin on
s'en occupe
alors pour pour le grand rock le
cavalier 1 on s'en fout un peu ça change
rien je perroquet c'est la Cavaillon 1
par contre là pour croquer enfin le
petit rock la dame en H1 on s'en fout un
peu ça sert à rien mais si je sors le
fou les cavaliers je pourrais faire le
petit rock de ce côté-là
juste pour répondre à Alex alors on va
aller voir contre nepo n'est pas qui est
obligé un peu de gagner pour garder
l'avance sur saw ah mais sauf qu'a perdu
c'est vrai oui match donc
sauf que gagner mais soupe nul donc par
rapport au classement je peux revoir
rapidement j'ai un petit doute
un petit doute par rapport aux
classements donc à Peter of qui va
sûrement
sûrement merci pour
donc nepoque à 5 et Soka 3 donc ce dans
le meilleur des cas il passe à 4
mais après une épaule je vous raconte
quand même contre gretharson donc du
coup ouais il faudrait que nepo perte
contre gretharson presque
là
donc ça reste pas mal de choses on a
envie de dire quand même que
les les groupes là sont quasiment
scellés entre tu vois les deux premiers
a besoin
de se qualifier en fait malgré la
défaite de dépôt
aussi bah ça dépend il y a juste un cas
c'est fait d'OCS qui baccal et ça y est
il y a un regroupement en tête et c'est
plus du tout quoi il y a ce suspense là
qui est très important après cette
partie là on en saura plus mais il y a
encore un suspense entre 4 scène et
philosophe mais le reste normalement on
sait que Naka n'est poméacci etc risque
très très grandes chances en tout cas de
se qualifier tous les trois
très dominants
dans l'autre groupe avec un très bon
fait d'ocif quand même qui est encore
salut Cyril qui a encore en course en
fait ouais
il faut super ce qu'il a fait jusque là
et il a été donc ce sera vraiment le
match je pense décisif ce 45 fait de CF
c'est ça qu'on regardera attentivement
bah je pense on l'a les noirs
on va voir parce que c'est pas ça dans
la partie
donc il a joué le début de qui avait
joué je crois que c'était des phénot CF
un petit peu la structure des blancs
prise
Foussais si c'est avec un beau vis-à-vis
donc un temps un petit peu
d'esthétiques pour casser la structure
et ouvrir vraiment
on voit l'initiative était incroyable
côté noir et ça a payé ça a payé à
pendule 22 minutes pour néo qui joue
comme s'il était en blitz et joue bien
il y a aussi un Caval de P4 qui traîne
attention
il faudrait pas se prendre ce petit mat
effectivement ou simplement
cette menace hyper embêtante bon sur
cavalier c'est trois dames prend ces
trois ne marcherait pas à cause de B
prend ses trois heureusement parce que
sinon qui est B4 c'était quasiment la
fin de partie
[Musique]
c'était une finale assez chaude
et on va dire que Greta sonne a eu la
réussite qui lui manquait depuis le
départ donc c'est quand même assez juste
mais il aurait pu ne pas gagner cette
partie là et gagner c'est le contrat de
12 à torov ça aurait été plus conforme
je pense la mérité l'annulation vraiment
hier il a eu le résultat inversé contre
adossa torov donc ça ça le rembourse un
petit peu puis même c'est le local de
l'étape bon c'est quand même bien que
qu'il soit pas complètement battu à
chaque fois et là il fera au moins un
match nul contre
wesleau il va peut-être tirer parce que
quand même il est pas il est pas en
forme dans ce tournoi non il est pas en
forme
mais ok bon ça reste quand même saut
mais il est pas en forme il fait
résultat un peu un peu timide
[Musique]
c'est une config où il peut faire
quelque chose quoi ouais
après on peut mettre une pièce en F4
peut-être pas mal pris sous son H5
tu aimes mais G4 par exemple sur un coup
qui je trouve hein serait niveau de la
structure catastrophique après ton
cavalier
ici il y a 100 en l'air ça en l'air en
fait tous les pions sont faibles et le
pion F en plus on a parlé tout à l'heure
dans la partie de Carl Seine l'option
qui qui est juste mal placé qui arriéré
qui qui pourra jamais
avancer
c'est très clair ce que tu expliques là
et c'est très sympa à comprendre mais on
comprend pas d'ailleurs les pièces
noires là c'est une grosse difficulté
dès l'ouverture alors c'est une
difficulté positionnelle il y a pas
encore de matériel en moins etc mais ça
va être très très difficile à jouer pour
pour
donc voyons voir ce qui se passe en tout
cas c'est une belle question
à jouer
l'idée DFC c'est de garder la structure
un peu mobiles et de pas donner la case
F4 pour l'instant mais si
oui la dame va sortir peut-être en F3
pour se mêler à la lutte il y a cavalier
F3 pour ajouter de la pression si après
revenir en cas de
4h
pour eux aussi on va profiter du foin à
8 pas très bien placé pour peut-être
préparer l'Europe et au-delà de ça
doubler en eux pour s'infiltrer pour
avoir des cavaliers aussi menaces non
c'est
il y a vraiment ouais on va aller comme
il y a quelque chose
je pense c'est la plus importante parce
que ben il y a c'est la seule partie je
pense qui qui est pas clair dans le sens
des résultats pour se qualifier
je vous rappelle que 15 scène en cas de
de nul ou de victoire
origam de très très bonne chance de se
qualifier
il y a une vraie une vraie bonne
question là de d'Alex d'un point de vue
[Musique]
c'est c'est quasiment aussi prestigieux
peut-être que je donnerai quand même un
peu de place aux vrais échecs au rapide
mais je trouve ça très très intéressant
d'être champion du monde après c'est
vraiment le prestige de la compète dans
ce cas-là le vrai championnat du monde
et plus enfin les vrais règles c'est
quand même un peu plus prestigieux par
contre l'intérêt
c'est quand même pour le 960 on a vu que
c'était quand même très très intéressant
ça montre une vraie compréhension du jeu
quoi alors moi je suis pas trop tout à
fait d'accord avec toi dis-moi parce
qu'en fait juste quand tu vois je place
du monde de blitzer rapide malgré le
fait que si tu Blitz c'est que c'est un
peu moins comme tu dis intéressant et
valorisant un peu que les les vrais
échecs pur c'est à dire des cadences
plus lentes etc
le championnat du monde de Blitz quand
même pour le gagner c'est juste
monstrueux quoi tu vois mvl a gagné
cette année il a fait un gros gros
compact dans ce tournoi mais je sais
plus combien la drones dans ce temps-là
mais il y a peut-être une trentaine de
parties ou vingtaine de parties dans le
championnats du monde et il faut
enchaîner comme un malade en fait les
résultats et tous les meilleurs du monde
sont là et du coup c'est c'est un
tournant en fait qui est tellement
difficile à gagner
qu'en fait tu vois tout le monde est là
en fait là dans ce tournoi
il faudrait par rapport aux 960 qui est
un plateau aussi relevé avec plus de
monde un format d'ailleurs Open et
d'ailleurs par rapport au prestige
finalement dans le format du tournoi on
va prendre maintenant c'est ça reste un
petit tournoi entre 8 personnes et 5
joueurs ça d'accord mais pour l'intérêt
je de la discipline l'intérêt échiquier
un pur mais il y a deux lectures en fait
à la question
parce que là c'est vrai que deux joueurs
là ils sont que ils sont que 8 joueurs
donc quatre par quatre par groupe et on
l'a des joueurs qui sont là mais qui
sont pas dans le top niveau c'est ça par
exemple
on pense aussi à
qui bon c'est un super-pouvoir mais il
est pas dans le top 10 on pense aussi à
au genre allemand bluebom tu vois là en
ce moment il manque quand même des
joueurs comme fille rouge là Caravana
Ding enfin il manque tout le monde en
fait donc en fait voilà c'est c'est
différent moi je si tu me proposes enfin
choisir entre championnats du monde de
Blitz c'est celui-là bah je prends le
Blitz parce que je trouve que pour
gagner il faut quand même
y aller un peu plus fort quoi tu vois
pas facile les questions à l'axe il a
décidé de nous poser pas mal de
questions et vous préférez vraiment des
championnats de France 2022 ou 2021
2021 mais elle a encore en plus ta c'est
pas facile d'y répondre parce qu'il y a
deux lectures là encore pour le
spectacle je prends que la 2022 et mieux
mais pour l'intérêt du du championnat et
du titre en lui-même le 2020 le 2021 et
était plus intéressant quoi je suis
d'accord mais le problème tu vois c'est
que le format 2021 va vraiment
comment dire
le les joueurs plus forts devront
normalement gagner le tournoi quoi et
alors que d'un tournoi au format 2022 ou
c'est l'élimination directe pas en fait
juste tu es pas en forme sur une partie
tu perds et au revoir quoi et du coup
difficile tu as pas le droit à l'erreur
on a quand même avec la nouvelle armure
une formule pardon u Moussa et Macron en
finale ce qui était
attendu en fait au final donc voilà on a
quand même eu
[Musique]
ouais une des finales les plus les plus
fortes possibles pour moi en tout cas
c'est deux enfin deux grands favorisés
les deux mecs que je passais devant
c'était c'était d'ailleurs je voyais
bien une victoire d'Etienne Bacro
d'ailleurs ce que j'avais
été tellement en forme que bon c'était
dur quand même à ce format là je préfère
et Jules enfin je passe préféré c'est
que je ouais je pensais que je voulais
te favori parce qu'en Blitz franchement
il est quand même vraiment fort
après il fait même là en ce moment aux
vrais échecs ils gagnent tout quoi tout
ce qui est égal il a gagné récemment un
tournoi je crois que c'est en croissance
de 1700 hello
comme ça je crois je pense actuellement
c'est pas 1700 c'est bien 2700 à
faire mal c'est
on va dire que Jul est en jaune était
attendu à ce niveau là puis il y avait
un petit peu calé on peut le dire et là
de depuis maintenant un an un peu plus
enfin il explose complètement à ce
niveau là en fait il avait un gros
potentiel il s'était pas encore affirmé
à un certain moment et là il est en
train de l'affirmer complètement et il
change de statut on va dire clairement
c'est vrai que Maxime Lagarde lui a fait
les frais c'est fait éliminer contre
romain Édouard et puis oui il y a juste
un aspect que tu peux avoir un appareil
Mans assez difficile aussi
ça ça peut être terrible oui clairement
il y avait quand même tu joues le
vainqueur de l'accession ou champion de
France junior c'est pas pareil que je
vois un grand maître expérimenté comme
il y a eu romain Edward Maxime Lagarde
c'était hyper dur quoi
relativement tard il faut regarder oui
en fait son titre de GM n'est pas d'une
hyper précocité et encore c'est tout à
fait correct mais il était champion du
monde ou vie champion du monde qui
poussin donc il était on l'attendait
très très fort voilà
il faudrait en discuter avec
l'intéresser mais c'est une histoire de
maturité dans le travail qui est
peut-être venu plus tard je sais pas je
pense qu'il y a quelque chose comme ça
mais en tout cas
moi je l'ai vu tout le temps gagner le
championnat de France etc de sa
catégorie
tout le temps aller en équipe de France
et je pense qu'il a acquis beaucoup
d'expérience et derrière il l'a valorisé
quand il a commencé à travailler dur
mais là encore c'est ça sera à lui de
s'exprimer il se connaît mieux
donc c'est ça qui était joué par parfait
de CF que tu en penses
critique on va dire de dans le genre de
position de toute façon j'ai peut-être
pas trop le choix non plus Stéphane
c'est aussi un choix par défaut parce
que ça reste quand même bizarre très
entreprenant etc mais sinon les blancs
commencent à installer leurs pièces et
j'étais quasiment si j'essaie fait faire
peut-être des choses je sais pas d'âme
c'est de Beckham ça pouvait commencer à
être et puis un cavalier en E5 je
pouvais commencer à être complètement
coincé quoi
même c'est ça que alors
c'est un coup qui peut paraître bizarre
parce qu'on va on va offrir au noir à la
case des 5 mais d'un autre côté ça prend
pas mal d'espace ça prend les cases du
cavalier à 4 mais j'avais vraiment le
temps dans le jardin c'est deux je me
lassais B3 et du coup c'était c'était
assez terrible donc il fallait qu'il
fasse quelque chose en fait c'est même
pas qu'il a fait avec un je pense qu'il
est 5 il est content de faire ces cinq
en disant bon de toute façon faut que je
trouve quelque chose oui le roi n'est
pas bien dans cette position le rond en
C8 tombe la tour en 18 on peut pas ok
parce que moi j'avais l'impression qu'il
allait faire ça tempo ça avait l'air
assez logique en fait d'essayer donc je
sais pas dans quel sens peut-être ça
c'est trop la position ça doit rester un
tout petit peu mieux
et avoir une position jouable mais en
fait c'est vrai que la pollution
peut-être c'est ça qui peut arriver
Michel est salut Jacques
ouais donc du coup
voilà et là dès 5 je trouve ça fort
bouger de C8 en fait voilà bah voilà
c'est parti et du coup c'est pénible
surtout il se passait quoi le 5 qui
pouvait arriver aussi
tu veux pas rester sur F7 ou sur des 5
et du coup
parce que attention
ne pas se prendre pour l'instant B3 il
n'y a pas parce que il y a cavalier C3
mais à tout moment on peut se prendre
des séquences d'âme c'est deux dans ma
F5 échec enfin tu vois des trucs aussi
il y a plein de choses
j'avais oublié aussi encore une fois le
petit rock possible qui a l'air très
bien joué un devoir grâce à
ça parce que du coup mon roi est en
sécurité alors que le sien
[Musique]
pour moi non je vais essayer
tu passes par un échec donc pour moi
c'est impossible je vais faire ça il est
vraiment ton roi passe forcément
j'avais même pas vu Michel nous indique
que la jauge sur petit rock 17 = mais
effectivement j'avais pas vu la jauge à
ce moment-là et et très très difficile
de jouer alors c'est un grand match de
renom donc il peut trouver peut-être les
coups précis mais ça donne vraiment pas
envie comme dit Michel humainement c'est
clair on voit BK
je pensais
deux je crois
[Musique]
j'ai plein de choses qui s'écartent
et ça a l'air en pratique c'est juste
très dur pour les Noirs
un coup un coup à chaque fois peut-être
d'un monsieur dame c'est de F5
la prise de KBF 4
c'est terrible pour moi
mais peut-être mais quel G5
souffle à la place
de
sur dame ces deux d'un F5 il y a
quelques
j'essaie de trouver une bricole tu vois
mais
donc si je pense que c'est bien ce que
tu as fait enfin il faut essayer et
dames ces deux je vais faire d'un F5
mais il y a peut-être ce cavalier H4
j'ai essayé tu vois de contre-attaquer
il y a quel âge 4 qui doit me faire mal
parce qu'en fait
tu manges là mais si je t'attaque ici
il faut faire attention
mais en fait je perds trop de temps
[Musique]
ça calme vraiment l'idée il y avait
donc il faut trouver ça va être dur pour
lui et maintenant sortir on se casse un
peu les dents d'ailleurs avec le noir
c'est pas normal parce que
comment on pourrait faire après je pense
que juste c'est hyper dur pour la non en
fait
c'est le seul coup pour pouvoir roquer
en fait tu vois
j'embrouille un peu plus la position
ok
je n'aime pas mais au moins j'essaie de
faire quelque chose quoi comme on a vu
depuis le départ c'est de profiter de
juste en fait si je mange genre en par
exemple et ok l'idée
ça montre aussi à tout le monde la
difficulté
encore une fois nous on vraiment son
ordinateur on s'amuse et on essaie de
vous montrer un peu le côté humain tout
ça mais en fait c'est hyper dur donc
Casso nous dit que la qualité des micros
est horrible alors ça c'est c'est
intéressant jusque là on a pas trop de
si c'est les deux micros ou c'est que le
solides souffre au colmiens n'hésitez
pas à dire en tout cas
si vous avez le ce que nous on s'entend
pas moi j'entends très bien et moi je
suis exactement c'est ça donc
alors juste je suis curieux Kevin je
vais mettre l'ordinateur qui me permet
il faut trouver les seuls coup à chaque
fois parce que
ordinateur et ça c'est le numéro 1
encore une fois tu vois les joueurs qui
jouent qui joue
qui joue hyper hyper précis quoi Tom
sérieux c'était le plus normal et là
j'ai fait avoir
je me suis dit c'est différent peut-être
que l'ordi laisse on enlève la Dame des
deux peut-être
tu peux pas envoyer
c'est très très dur
[Musique]
c'est très très dur à ps5
mais si quand tu cherches des Français 4
il faut voir ça ça derrière c'est juste
très très dur quoi donc en plus on est
en rapide
c'est hyper compliqué mais en pratique
encore une fois les coupes blanche sont
facile tu vois j'ai ça j'ai tourné un
j'ai de la musique mes coups sont très
faciles en fait donc du coup c'est noir
qui qui sont en
difficulté que ça soit tous les coups et
c'est pour ça que du coup je pense qu'il
est petit rock était vraiment super
bonne
parce que c'est trop dur pour les
enfants
on peut imaginer 31 par exemple
on passe tous les pièces très facilement
et comme on fait en face
[Musique]
mais maintenant je peux passer de
l'autre côté cavalier G5 tours
c'est vraiment archi pénible
ça évite que le cavalier soit en prise
je me disais et maintenant après dame
c'est tout je sais pas trop dans quel
sens mais en fait j'ai juste envie de
ramener du monde à la fête et du coup
mais bon je suis
tout est très dur en fait et
franchement je ne suis pas cher de la
peau de fait dehors dans cette partie
quand même par fedo mais on voit que ce
joue quand même très bien de les parties
qui la fête parce que finalement je sais
pas il y a 40 points de plus que blueba
mais c'est quand même pas le même monde
je trouve la qualité des parties de CF
parce que il arrive à non pas dans les
positions simples à tenir c'est vraiment
il met le bordel sur l'échiquier il va
qu'on les met qui il a le niveau quoi en
fait tu as fait le Sega c'est quand même
ancien joueur à moitié de 50
uranium on est dans les chasse 960 alors
c'est vrai que c'était joueur débutant
ça peut un peu de choquer au niveau des
Rocks
oui parce que ouais je comprends
la position de départ comme dit Michel a
été tiré au sort c'est le chef 90
positions possibles au départ donc on
est vraiment sur une variante du jeu
d'échec très spécifique c'est les échecs
sans théorie ou la position de départ
n'était pas la même que celle que tu
connais habituellement regarde c'est à
cette position là au départ donc
effectivement le roi et la tour ne
doivent pas avoir bougé et on va
retrouver la position finale d'un rock
classique donc le roi ancien sur sa case
et la tour B qui passe en D1 par exemple
dans le cas d'un grand rock et pour un
petit rock bah ça sera de l'autre côté
quand on va enlever tes fous et ton
cavalier tu pourras faire le petit rock
sur les cases en rouge mais il faut
avoir enlevé un fouet fin et cavalier
donc à ce jeu là seul les rocks sont
vraiment difficiles à comprendre
ouais ça c'est difficile et
d'ailleurs on a vu hier la la grosse
cagoule de de saut qui a qui a perdu
contre contre un dépôt
pour faire rapide
son épaules je sais pas si je peux vous
le montrer
je vais rien dire Cyril parce que hier
je l'ai déjà dit tu vois donc ça va je
suis content
ici c'est la partie d'hier juste un
dépôt saut juste pour voir il y a eu
enfin en fait chaud il s'est laissé
faire mater du couloir bon c'est pas mat
mais vous voyez que je perds je perd
toutes mes pièces et je mets les pièces
devant quoi mais il s'est laissé prendre
ça en fait parce qu'il pensait ici pour
faire petit rock
parce que en fait on a pas le droit de
faire normalement voilà là je perroquet
en fait j'ai le droit d'accord c'est
légal
dans cette position mais malheureusement
bah quand je suis quand je suis en échec
donc là bas c'est pareil c'est la même
règle que le sexe standard en fin au
final donc
on le disait un ciel tombe elle est pas
jouée
elle n'est pas jouée on a dit ça en
début de streaming il y avait vraiment
960 positions mais 9059 comme l'a dit
Cyril parce que la note soit un thème
c'est celle de base elle ne sera pas
jouée si on tombe dessus
c'est logique aussi mais il a pas le
temps sans doute
est-ce que tu penses que fait le CF il a
oublié le petit rat de Manu ça parce
qu'en fait quand il a juste 5
des 5 c'est quand même un coup logique à
regarder
on va regarder cette position à la place
de ces 5 qu'est-ce qu'on peut jouer avec
les Noirs c'est je pense c'est vraiment
pas facile
on a vu quand même
les joueurs cherchent beaucoup
l'initiative c'est juste enlever madame
pour faire cavalier B6 tu vois ce que je
veux dire sauf bon alors niveau je
comprends que ça soit hyper saoulant
donc qui joue c'est 5 pour brouiller les
pistes et après c'est sûr qu'il a pas
tout anticipé mais de toute façon il
faut prendre des décisions
à chaque fois tu vois ils doivent
prendre une décision
j'aurais bien été du style à jouer ces
cinq par rapport à mon problème du
cavalier A4 j'ai envie de régler le
problème du cavalier A4 c'est vrai qu'il
fait d'autres concessions mais ça c'est
le jeu d'échec quoi et là juste donc
l'idée donc là fais le Stef qui a un
mauvais bolide il est il est compliqué
[Musique]
il a son ticket pour la demi-finale
exactement de CFI
et est-ce qu'on va avoir un Carlson
Nakamura de gala où tu penses que
Carlsen va
pas s'arranger mais bon ils vont jouer
tranquille et faire nul quoi
en fait si les deux joueurs sont
qualifiés je pense qu'ils vont se taper
dans la gueule
je pense hein
ben je pense aussi d'autant plus qu'il a
bien il a bien merdouillé hier vous vous
l'avez vu
du coup avec c'était avant-hier du coup
excuse-moi
un coup ben comme on fait des fois en
Bullet ou en 3-0 et qu'on est déjà pas
content donc pour lui c'était story quoi
non clairement donc du coup non je pense
qu'il y aura une partie en fait enfin
ils vont jouer je pense
si les deux joueurs étaient
tu vois encore en train de voir gagner
leur place pour la demi-finale je pense
que j'aurais dû partir rapide tu vois
des pièces sur 100 points de risque mais
là du coup l'objectif est atteint les
deux joueurs
il va se faire plaisir car ça ne veut
prendre sa revanche je pense que ça va
jouer personne mais ouais pour répondre
à la question de Cyril oui pour moi très
clairement
abdosa t'aura c'est c'est extrêmement
fort
on l'a vu à tous les cadences maintenant
il est peut-être
en dessous aujourd'hui d'aller raisin
mais c'est pour moi c'est pas clair
c'est à dire qu'il est tellement jeune
qu'on peut pas dire mais ce qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'il va être dans les dans
le top 10 mondial à un moment ça c'est
sûr après il est hyper talentueux c'est
pas bien encore une fois regarde là il
est champion du monde rapide et là il
est en tête du championnat du monde
de chasse aux 60 mais encore une fois
c'est du rapide tu vois donc
pour moi le classique n'a rien à voir
avec le jeu rapide ça c'est première
chose mais après
il a été monstrueux aux Olympiades et
d'ailleurs son pays a gagné a gagné les
Olympia du premier échecier etc et il a
un gros potentiel il est hyper un bosser
ça se voit très motivé et très
talentueux donc il y a aucun doute sur
le fait qu'il va être dans le top
mondial dans les années à venir
parce qu'il y a souvent des positions
des demandes comme celle-là ça on peut
pas dire c'est à dire qu'entre être dans
le top 10 et confirmé d'être tout le
temps dans le top 5 et après être numéro
un comme l'a fait Carlson ça c'est
monstrueux parce que 45 ça fait une
décennie qu'il est incontesté le maître
du jeu quoi c'est à proprement parler
quoi donc c'est le top du top quoi
et Michel qui nous demande qui entraîne
à boussole je ne suis pas capable de
répondre tu sais peut-être
je sais pas mais j'ai juste vu aux
Olympiades il y avait l'air d'avoir
comment il s'appelle
[Musique]
un rapport un peu peut-être privilégié
avec lui je pense que c'est pas
impossible du tout de chocolat fontaine
du coup
rapidement voir ce qui s'est passé
vraiment on a la bonne position
c'est la bonne position
voilà je pense qu'il va le trouver mais
il cherche encore voir s'il y a pas mal
il va
je vais vous mettre la grande caméra
juste pour que vous voyez ça va être la
fin de la partie vous voyez un petit peu
et
je cherche le meilleur
néerland du coup et là il sait que il
sait que c'est abandonné il sait qu'il
est qualifié pour cette primeur
demi-finale qui aura lieu d'ailleurs
samedi en compagnie de Kevin bordi
stream sur la même chaîne
donc faudra regarder ça parce que ça va
vous faire maintenant quoi vraiment là
ça fait trois jours qu'on est
franchement trouvé ça génial donc tiens
on voit j'y vais cet événement là si
vous avez le temps en tout cas et
regarde un dépôt qui a encore perdu
contre
contre App Store
quelqu'un nous mettait ça désolé donc
merci Cyril mais effectivement tout à
l'heure il était pas très bien pourtant
l'ouverture attends ça fait 4-0 quand
même
j'ai fait bien
manger ça te fait au dessus je pense
qu'on a raté ouais je
ils ont tout changé
on s'était arrêté à l'ouverture qui
avait bien réussi son ouverture il était
en grande instance au temps en 6 minutes
par contre il n'a pas réussi à faire la
différence
le petit rock toujours
et le petit rock qui a changé la partie
ça a changé la donne au niveau des rois
je vais assez vite pour mais le roi noir
qui est encore une fois toujours en
difficulté
même quand il perd il peut il peut
perdre extrêmement rapidement ça ne le
dérange pas donc là il y a eu un joli
sacrifice de qualité ton point est fuite
avec tout Rouen qui menace maintenant en
et 8 voilà échec et Damien
je tourne qui va monter aussi et du coup
tu peux pas défendre
pour le match
ça sera aussi d'éviter de cette Europe
parce que même si on a dit que tous les
mecs se valaient on voit quand même que
on n'a pas envie de le jouer à nous ça
aura vu la forme qu'il a après ça veut
rien dire comme on l'a dit en poule on
peut avoir une grande forme et puis
après ben on perd le minimache 1 et demi
sur deux on rentre chez soi quoi
[Musique]
normalement c'est quand même tout est
meilleur joueur en dans cette cadence là
et très créature tous les deux je les
vois quand même mal
se faire marcher dessus par le petit
jeune même si bon c'est clair encore
ils vont quand même donner je pense
la dernière match d'ailleurs on a un peu
oublié
parce qu'on savait que que la partie ne
changerait absolument rien dans le dans
les événements
mais on va voir du coup il reste cette
partie là et c'est là c'est aussi notre
partie de notre ami Greta Sarson je sais
pas si tu veux tu veux on peut faire un
petit tour
de la position tu vas pas me dire que
greterson va tenir cette position on a
resté sauf à gagner
[Musique]
il y a une pièce de plus pour
quand même trois pions et pas trop trop
d'échelle bon échec là qui peut qui peut
prier quand même par contre ouais
mais après un coup comme par exemple 3
B8 peut-être à jouer échec revenir non
oui
c'est incroyable la différence de temps
n'est pas qui joue tout hyper vite
de niveau quand on voit le qui sont
capables de produire
d'excellentes
mais très très rapidement et oui ce
petit dame j'ai 8 pour éviter les âmes
C8 comme ça j'ai toujours de la mâchette
ouais c'est mieux regardez s'il y avait
eu ça peut-être que dame là était
possible donc préfère du coup aller
enlever vite au cas où c'est la dame
venait ici je pouvais manger le pion en
H7 donc là il va y avoir une nulle je
pense un roi roi 7 et la lame va revenir
ici attaquer là et Nakamura ne peut pas
défendre
et du coup il est pas l'air content
Nakamura il fait un peu la tête
parce qu'il a pas envie de lâcher un
demi point
mais bon ça va faire nul celle-là je
pense donc c'est quand même cool pour
homme qui est bon qui fait qu'un
résultat dans ce dans ce dans cette
histoire noir parce que bon je compte
Nakamura c'est jamais facile
c'est justement assez joli quand on a eu
la pression longtemps comme il a dû la
voir toute la partie on finit à 45
secondes contre 14 minutes franchement
ça fait bien plaisir même de sauver un
demi point de cette enfin sauver ou de
prendre un demi point de cette manière
donc ça va faire nul on va aller voir
aussi ce qui se passe chez So
avec grande difficulté quand même
donc peut-être penser à thoracisme voilà
qui était le seul coup parce que si le
fou vous venez à partir quand je
prendrai à Sète donc là faut quand même
voir qu'il y a plusieurs pions de moi
[Musique]
il y a deux jambes directement mais
c'est fou que le reposer 4
ça donne un pion supplémentaire que je
pourrais quand même éviter de donner
parce que là et comment je vais me
sortir de
du business là c'est pas facile
vous voyez
il faut penser au fond de couleur opposé
je sais pas si je peux jouer des dessins
qui doit être en train de regarder Greta
reson comment tenir ses positions ça va
pas être facile de temps encore une fois
regarde là il va tomber
en tout cas chez moi j'ai plus de temps
je ne sais pas je vois pas la caméra la
caméra elle est sur et sur Nakamura
et là il faut qu'il trouve
des coûts très très vite là
je pense la position elle est très dure
en pratique il y a de plus de moi et
c'est la reposer mais
[Musique]
bon il faut trouver des coquins ces
quatre c'est pas un coup
c'est juste attendre mais
peut-être dessin comme Pierre a proposé
pour voir parce qu'il se passe il faut
prendre des seins
à 6 cette position doit pas être facile
quand même à gagner
oui il faut que je fasse gaffe à un
thème F5 F4 tu sais stouf et en même
temps depuis on a mes salaires suffisant
comme contrôle je pense que
je laisse mon roi ici et je bouge mon
foie à chaque fois je vois pas comment
tu passes
[Musique]
donc des sacs intéressants
et la prise n'est pas possible
de prendre non plus mais au moins donc
maquillage a pas pris la nul
je suis retourné sur Naka il a il a
laissé pour manger pour manger des sacs
ouais mais il y aurait nul quand même
c'est ça
bon il a essayé il y a des idées mais
non il a pas d'idée
c'est pareil
il essaie tout le temps vraiment il aime
bien continuer continuer surtout quand
l'autre est mal au temps mais au final
je pense pas qu'il va
[Musique]
essayer de faire
pour gagner un peu de temps
[Musique]
car elle va aller prendre des 6 il y a
peut-être
en tout cas c'est un peu plus c'est un
peu compliqué la vie d'accord mais bon
en se compliquant la vie il peut aussi
que bon il a il a rien à perdre toute
façon
brouiller l'autre il aime beaucoup il
joue
c'est il est content il joue
donc là ce qui peut essayer de faire
c'est mon dessin avec échec et poussette
qui ont h
en tout cas
donc attention
les dames sont échangées un purge qui
peut courir
donc roi des cas de grosses gaffes froid
c'est 5 grosses gaffes attention ça
c'est pas fini encore bon
Rebecca très chèque ah oui c'est pareil
en fait
tu perds la dame non
elle a réussi encore à trouver des
ressources punaises
quand le roi va commencer à se remettre
en place pour faire gaffe aussi avec les
noirs
sur le chèque il faut voir si je peux
et en plus ça faisait perpète même de
toute façon au pire du pire du pire quoi
donc c'est quand même pas si simple
c'est à dire qu'il peut prendre à trois
mais si je fais le tour avec mon roi
et c'est de ramener la dame ça peut être
quoi comme un chèque je sais pas mais il
faudrait que j'arrive
il va venir sûrement en dessert la dix
minutes contre 10 secondes c'est quand
même trois pions il a fait ça
et juste avec les Blancs j'ai pas de
coup
moi je pense que je pense qu'il va raser
je pense que peut-être mal au temps et
je sais pas pourquoi mais je pense que
je pense qu'il va blender à notre ami
allemand il est pas confiant en tout cas
il fait il fait grise mine ouais
de refuser la nuit là il est là pour
s'amuser je peux plus rien
non mais c'est vrai je pense qu'il faut
jouer quoi
il est très fort il a fait en pratique
un truc incroyable c'est à dire qu'il a
laissé la perpète à l'autre et la
possibilité de jouer pour que si l'autre
jour arrivait dans ce style de position
ou l'autre peut déconner quel que soit
on sait que un super niveau mais avec 10
secondes à la pendule tu as beau avoir
un super niveau
tu es en danger
ça répète un petit peu
mais je pense que Naka il va essayer de
jouer maintenant il a fait le plus dur
pour pour jouer d'ailleurs ça me paraît
bizarre que n'a qu'à fasse nul ici
[Musique]
parce que on a l'impression qu'il allait
jouer tu sais si tu veux faire nul tu
fais nul quoi avant
là
un peu dégoûté
de pas lui mettre la pression avec la 10
secondes c'est très très intéressant
encore une fois
et je reviens si tu me prends pas donc
du coup ça soit tout à 4 qui peut être
une idée
là manger ici mais quand même le roi
tactile qui peut tomber c'est ça mais
bon j'ai toujours une majorité avec un
peu passé ici
les noirs doivent être un peu mieux
surtout que le pur F2 bah il compte pas
trop parce que il est
arrierait quoi tout simplement
donc ok c'est 4 intéressants l'idée
c'est vraiment d'essayer de vouloir
casser la structure des Noirs je pense
qu'il faut manger non
j'ai pas envie en fait de me laisser le
petit pion passé à quoi peut-être pas
mal
à Kevin qui est qui est parti
Kevin qui nous a lancé
[Musique]
petite blague petite blague
donc
c'est super bien joué le principe de
liquidation sauf j'étais en train de
dire ça et bam après j'ai sauté c'est ça
mais c'est un super coup mais les noirs
il y a encore du travail mais c'est
hyper bien joué c'est qu'un parce que
tous les problèmes je pense tu as tombé
si jolie c'est joli bien sûr
être très joli donc ceux qui continuent
à jouer mais
[Musique]
normalement
les chances de s'imposer dans ce
dans ce groupe et quasiment terminé je
crois
perdus
bon
ça va être au niveau des scores ça va
faire que même
greterson peut gagner contre contre
sceaux et c'est terminé dans ce cas là
si ici il y a match nul dans cette
partie c'est terminé tout de suite oui
mais
six ou cassé partie il peut gagner
favorable quoi je dirais parce que
gretharson jouerait contre nepo et lui
jouera tousatoires c'est quand même pas
le moment pareil moi mais il faut
espérer sur un exploit de réthardson
[Musique]
bon et maintenant est-ce qu'on
liquiderait pas encore les filles avec
tous vos deux tours de cartes c'est
possible avec les
Blancs
cyrilin juste même une nulle genre
chez Greta Sun contenait pas et lui
battre
ça peut pas être au départ de partage
faudra avoir après exactement comment
les départages mais
est-ce que tu connais le départage Kevin
en cas de match nul
total d'égalité à la fin
passe une bonne question bon il fera un
mille match
je pense que c'est le score de la
victoire sûrement
avant sur les classements de chacun pour
des
jouets est-ce que tu veux par exemple
sur cette partie
et une minute chacun un Greta toujours
quoi donc alors attends
qu'est-ce que je pense de cette position
parce que ça avance alors
qui va se faire j'ai pas envie de varier
là
puis on faible là le pion a qui est
passé
il y a un moment c'était nul au niveau
de la jauge mais je pense que cette
position elle est difficile voilà bah ça
commence déjà sans doute tout à 5 est
terminé
ça y est ça doit être vraiment perdu
cette position maintenant
tu as pris le coup après
je crois que mon roi là
je vais faire à trois
là moi qui va monter en B2
couleur opposées non il a bien joué
en pratique tu vois il garde il garde
des tours plutôt que les fous parce que
souvent nul et il est quand même de
bonnes chances de gains
c'est pas encore fini
mais pour voyager jusqu'à en bas mais
bon en pratique il faut trouver les cons
encore
là je pense que ça va être tout de suite
dur parce que à trois à deux à trois à
deux maintenant il y aura la tour en 1
et comment je fais en fait je peux plus
bouger une oreille
parce que même si jamais les tours
s'échangent en fait
donc du coup
là je mange des cinq cerf en bon
[Musique]
pas te laisser voilà ce sera pas contre
je alors
[Musique]
là il y a plus de
il est encore il était pas loin Greta
Arson
oui parce qu'il arrive quand même à
mettre le roi ouais mais là
[Musique]
c'est très dur
je pense abandon
c'est parti
4 on a tout de la pièce active ça
saurait si maintenant tu vas pas de coup
c'est parti
grosse technique de saut dans cette
partie
mise à jour il a eu il a eu du mal mais
ça l'a fait donc ça fait un lance une
image
on va regarder rapidement si ils ont mis
les
à jour les résultats de groupe
le score à la renvoie bon à Ostrov qui a
10 sur 10 juste une grosse machine quoi
et donc nepo on avait dit un qui malgré
ce défaites
parce que greterson il a un maintenant
c'est vrai ça fait 1 et 4 exactement
1 donc lui c'est pas grand chose il est
un petit peu hors-jeu par rapport à ça
et du coup so il a un point de moins
mais ce prochain match fut contre
saint-orov qui est hyper chaud qui est
qui est chaud bouillant devant avec
opération de gagner et du coup en plus
de l'occasion de gagner et ben il faut
qu'il prie pour que les pommeN Hatchi ne
gagne pas contre gretharson donc ça fait
quand même beaucoup niveau stable
niveau stats quand même des pommes de
terre largement devant
on va voir comment ça
comment ça ça joue mais en tout cas
c'est c'est
très difficile pour ceux de se qualifier
ici d'autant plus que 100 durant
tout le tournoi à montrer qu'il était
pas hyper hyper en forme donc ça serait
assez logique qui ne s'impose pas en
minima je contre un bout à toi pourquoi
pas match nul hein même s'il s'impose
donc en fait il a plus de temps entre sa
mort plus vraiment et normalement là on
va on va surtout assister à un Carlson
un aka de gala c'est ce qu'on peut
espérer dans le dans le groupe B pour la
première place du groupe quoi c'est ça
donc là du coup on a quand même qu'un
scène Naka qui sont à 8 points chacun
donc ils vont jouer quand même pour bon
déjà pour le gain du groupe mais aussi
vous voyez que le numéro 1 du groupe a
je crois contre le numéro 2 du groupe B
du coup là plutôt grave qui est premier
je vous vois contre le numéro 2 en fait
si jamais il y a un perdant dans ce
groupe là et ben du coup
il jouera contre contre le gagnant du
groupe a bien sûr donc du coup là ça
dépend est-ce que Cassen veut jouer
contre une peau ou un peu je pense que
je pense que franchement vu la format
actuel des joueurs même si comme tu l'as
dit il sonne fort que soit Naka ou
Carlson ils sont tellement forts qui
peuvent jouer tout le monde de manière
maligne autant jouer en 2000 avec un qui
est moins en forme
après je pense que c'est à peu près et
je pense quand même que par principe
Carcès ne veut gagner son groupe et puis
en fait ils ont envie de jouer tous les
deux on sait que il y a une rivalité
entre 45 Naka et du coup
ils vont aller la pousser jusqu'au bout
ouais donc du coup nous on va vous
laisser après une petite une petite
page de pub
légèrement plus longue parce que vous
savez il y a le tirage etc je pense
qu'ils vont reprendre les joueurs vers
40-45 mais cette fois-ci on sera bien là
pour le redémarrage voilà donc la ronde
aura lieu normalement à 45 mais un
nouveau tout tirage au sort avec un
nouveau tirage au sort qui va prendre un
petit peu de temps normalement vers 30 à
peu près vous aurez vous aurez le non là
j'ai pas la caméra malheureusement c'est
la pub je voulais vous montrer en fait
le tirage au sort qui va avoir lieu je
pense environ 10 minutes et donc le
tiroir des positions qui vont jouer pour
la dernière ronde donc en tout cas on va
les avoir 10 minutes et la partie qui
jouera dans environ une vingtaine de
minutes voilà voilà en tout cas nous on
revient pour le tirage au sort donc à
tout de suite je ne te partais pas
rester connecté je vous embête de pub en
attendant pour le gros choc yes à tout
de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes revenus les amis
avec du coup le tyrannosaure qui va
arriver dans quelques instants donc on
vous laisse vraiment le le plein écran
là pour pour ce moment
les joueurs qui sont là qui qui
attendent vraiment le la sortie des des
positions certains sont avec leur
entraîneur ils vont aller réfléchir
ensemble à comment commencer
la dernière partie
beaucoup plus de temps que
que tout à l'heure forcément mais c'est
bizarre que le tirage n'est pas encore
été fait
donc la partie de recommencer
normalement à 45
et
plus en plus dubitatif c'est à dire que
ouais je pense ils ont tardé à
mettre en place
[Musique]
dès qu'il les ont et bien
il y aura l'armement quinzaine de
battements pour aller en rouge et
effectivement les pots se prend un petit
truc à manger mais en même temps c'est
logique aussi franchement les joueurs
enfin dans ces dans ces parties animées
etc bah forcément il y a tous les
besoins qu'on peut avoir autre du coup
c'est logique de s'alimenter quoi
donc en patiente ça va sortir donc là on
voit les joueurs si vous ne les
connaissez pas on a créé catharsson en
premier plan avec juste un côté so
Wesley à droite on a le genre allemand
au fond on a le
l'entraîneur et aussi manager je pense
un de carte scène
quelle est ma dans les poches
et vous avez peut-être vu aussi il y
avait le contrôle maintenant c'est on
est dans l'aéro pourquoi à chaque fois
tu as vu tout enfin les contrôles à
l'entrée c'est c'est tout nouveau mais
c'est bien et c'est aussi un peu
rassurant au final
dans ce type de tournoi d'ailleurs
il sait qu'il est
un peu saoulé par ce contrôle mais bon
c'est quand même lui qui a cherché à la
base ce qui est tout ça
donc OK
allez hop il va passer il y a pas de
fouille encore dans les stades de foot
aussi la palpation quoi tu vois les
choses vraiment jusqu'au bout souffle
mais
je suis pas sûr que ce soit des joueurs
mais bon
ça serait pas logique à la position qui
arrive
alors on va découvrir ensemble la
position donc les pions devant c'est
normal vous voyez comment ça se passe
c'est 4 on sent l'ouverture B4 j'ai pas
encore vu la suite mais
du coup à 5 pour les Noirs
à côté c'est marrant ça
[Musique]
la position qu'on aura qu'on va avoir
un grand rock de folie quoi ça va faire
un grand rock bah un frère en rock on va
dire
enfin presque quasiment vrai un grand
grand rock mais
je trouve que cette pollution assez
sympa pour un pour un début de partie
pour pour un début
j'aime bien B4 la perso
donc là il se dépêche ils vont tous
à leur échiquier s'entraîner pendant un
petit quart d'heure pour voir ce qu'il
ce qu'ils vont jouer donc la stratégie
donc j'aimerais bien avoir aussi moi
aussi un échec comme ça malheureusement
échiquier va être un petit peu de temps
à me préparer généralement
tu vois parce que là on aurait pu
discuter un petit peu sur on aurait pu
se faire notre prépa on aurait pu faire
donc vous inquiétez pas on va rester
attendez je suis trompé de Cannes on va
rester là dessus je vais vous remettre
d'ailleurs l'autre cam
et on va essayer de voir ce qui se passe
et de
chaque fois je vais fraîche parce que si
on a une position donc si on peut
essayer de deviner les coups mais là on
a plus la position malheureusement je
l'ai pas regardé
sur une scène échec en direct je passe à
ça bon après c'est un peu et on pourrait
rentrer
mais
à la mano si tu veux attends là tu es
sur web tu
mets un échec un échec
en direct on arrivera à préparer
là dans trois quatre minutes on va avoir
les la partie mais on va pouvoir un
petit BK je pense quasiment dans toutes
les parties
très très
normal dans ses positions donc on verra
vraiment si ça joue ou pas
donc je préfère
Henry fraîche on refait toujours pas la
position
toujours un petit peu mais ça c'est cool
quand même de finir avec un petit Naka
de Seine je trouve ça cool qui est
rigolo c'est de voir à quel point les
joueurs donc 45 il était pas très prédé
dès qu'il a eu la position il courait
presque pour aller chercher son
échiquier et regarder la position c'est
clair donc il se prête il se prête pas
mal au jeu quand même ils ont pas envie
[Musique]
un petit peu leur amour propre tout ça
ils veulent bien faire ils veulent bien
finir et
voilà quoi donc
non moi je pense qu'on peut attendre ici
quand même un
beau match entre ces deux joueurs
en tout cas la poule B a la poule de
Carcel Nakamura elle est terminée les
deux
premiers s'affrontent mais peu importe
ce qui se passe ils vont être ils vont
être premier du groupe de qualifier par
contre dans le groupe a et ben comme
tout à l'heure on l'a dit hein je vais
vous montrer le classement actuel
par le groupe a on avait une possibilité
encore avec bon le premier c'est
champion du groupe qui a rasé
complètement l'événement avec 10 sur 10
après la moitié du mini match on va y
voir très clair en fait
[Musique]
mais là déjà je moi je viendrai quand
même un bon 80 même plus 90% pour pour
en forme après il va se battre quand
même parce que c'est un joueur qui adore
les échecs quoi on voit que ils sont
rompus de toute façon c'est clair un
accompagne mais par exemple là ne dépend
[Musique]
un petit quelque chose mais dites-moi
dites-moi dans le chat si vous êtes
d'accord avec moi franchement il y a un
petit quelque chose qui sonne pas très
russe et dites le moi si vous avez vu
pas ce petit toc parce que j'ai remarqué
et voilà je me dis qu'on a le temps pour
en parler là c'est le bon moment tu vois
c'est c'est la pause c'est que les
joueurs préparent leurs parties on n'a
pas encore l'échiquier mais je vais
actualiser quand même merci baron merci
baron je voulais entraîner quelqu'un
avec moi et ben on m'a répondu présent
c'est cool et salut merci à toi
il est solide donc ok
c'est pas le fait d'adorer les nuls
comme par un peu guéri et ben il y a eu
un marchandement contrôlé pendant très
longtemps les gens c'est le joueur qui
faisait le plus devenues etc et qui a un
genre qui a adoré ça il y a plein de
même tu vois mais en fait au final Giri
c'est un genre quand même qui est qui
joue pour le gars à chaque fois mais
même si des fois c'est pas forcément
voir on le voit pas tu vois mais il veut
qu'on le garde mais après derrière
et qu'elle n'a pas forcément mais c'est
pas parce qu'il adore faire nul c'est
juste que mais par contre guéri c'est un
joueur qui est assez offensif c'est un
genre qui
qui joue pour gagner à chaque fois ça
dépend des périodes aussi bon et puis de
toute façon quand vous êtes exposé c'est
toujours pareil on vous colle facilement
une étiquette quelconque et du coup
c'est pas c'est pas si évident quoi
voilà ça a bien changé aussi il y a une
période où c'était plus criant comme
maintenant les joueurs évoluent aussi
ils font ils font des progrès non pas
réellement techniquement parce qu'ils
sont déjà tellement forts mais c'est des
fois psychologiquement sur l'aspect
confiant jouer toutes les partis pour
gagner ça peut être des points de
progression même pour le haut niveau et
il y a des moments où vous êtes moins en
forme moins stable psychologiquement et
c'est plus dur il faut se remettre on
aura aussi un match finalement blueborne
fait dossiere même si il joue pour rien
on fait dossier enfin super tournoi il a
pas envie de de perdre contre loubarum
et en plus de quoi Booba dois jouer
aussi pour gagner un mi-match mettre un
point ça fait un peu la loose je trouve
de finir à zéro pour un mec comme ça
pour rien mais il joue quand même pas
pour rien quand même tant que ça parce
que
finalement tu vois les quatre premiers
donc tu vas sûrement avoir car celle n'a
qu'à dépôt je pense n'est pas et après
par rapport aux quatre suivants et ben
je te rappelle que quand même des prix
donc je te revois on va les montrer un
peu les prix et en fait vous voyez donc
les quatre premiers on les a dit après
c'est 25000 20000 15000 et pour les
quatre qui qui ne sont pas qualifiés le
3 se termine en fait aujourd'hui et donc
du coup ils vont prendre le placement
actuel et faire ça donc pour l'instant
ben fais de séguf et so ils sont entre
20-25
et vous aussi
directe tu vois et bon il y a quand même
de l'argent en jeu en fait et ce qui est
intéressant ce qui est intéressant c'est
que tu vois en fait on en a parlé hier
du côté financier un peu de tout ça
c'est que au final
tous les dépôts n'a qu'à moi un quartier
ils ont beaucoup d'argent ils sont genre
pro et qui aiment très très bien leur
vie à ce niveau là mais les joueurs
comme
ça je l'ai pas inclus parce qu'il est
plus dans le dans le haut niveau mais il
gagne leur vie de plus modestement donc
ils sont aussi genre pro hein etc mais
par exemple bluebom je pense qu'il y a
pas le même salaire que soprano
à 5000 e c'est pas mal ou 5000 dollars
quoi c'est pas mal c'est pas mal et pas
mal vu je pensais qu'on était dans le
beau jeu sauf que m'avait toujours
habitué à ce genre de discours
maintenant c'est un discours beaucoup
plus orienté tune je vois que depuis que
tu me voles mes subs
[Musique]
tu vois donc je pense que voilà c'est il
y a quand même de l'enjeu c'est cool bon
pour le 4 premiers ça changera rien par
contre
ce soir il va pouvoir s'acheter un petit
costume
soirée nickel il va changer le costume
alors on va vous mettre la salle on va
un peu ce qui se passe ici vous voyez
que les joueurs sont pas encore
installés ils sont encore à se préparer
est-ce que il y a pas il y a pas eu de
le refresh tu as pas eu la position
essayer d'avoir le refresh
et toujours pas je te rappelle hier
quand tu souffles le petit le petit
moment régalade que tu nous avais fait
en nous montrant la tour placée en
cavalier B1 la poussée d'ailleurs
j'ai je t'ai envoyé sur discord
je vais je vais de ce pas vous le
partager sur le sur le chemin
regardez ça ça vous fera attendre
tranquillement en vrai ouais en vrai ça
s'est passé hier je l'ai créé tout à
l'heure et aller voir ça ça sympa c'est
pas fait exprès du tout juste un gros
noob mais mais dans l'idée c'était assez
marrant ces petits clip
il y a toujours des petits moments
marrants à chaque fois qu'on stream
comme ça pendant plusieurs heures c'est
marrant il y a des petits craquages
c'est complètement craqué je disais au
début ça commence bien les pollution
elle est bien placé et en fait
regardez ce clip que tout vient de vous
mettre dans dans le chat parce que c'est
un pur moment de bonheur Néandertal
particulièrement franchement si tu l'as
pas encore vu j'ai plus c'était là à ce
moment là
tout finalement se trouve sympa sage
sache là
car un coup j'ai été sur ton stream et
quand je te laisse je l'ai mal pris ah
écoute bah je me suis pas
ouais mais là là il a grave progressé en
plus en ce moment donc ça tombe bien
qu'on en parle il est de retour dans la
phase où j'ai perdu 100 points et l'eau
que j'étais à 10 points c'est que là
j'avais la coupe dans la main et puis on
me l'a enlevé on m'a jeté on m'a jeté au
lion et donc ok je sais pas peut-être
que en tout cas il est possible en tout
cas je m'en excuse et content que que je
remonte un peu dans ton estime en tout
cas
je sais pas comme ça là je contre
et tu sais quand je contre à la belote
généralement je me fais sur contrer
alors on va voir un peu ce que dire par
en couple
j'adore la belote par contre je suis je
suis 50 mauvais tout mais tous mes amis
me disent ça mais
c'est un jeu la belote qui est hyper
apprécié par Joey chacun il y a beaucoup
beaucoup
encore d'ailleurs avec de très forts
joueurs
c'est
Léo battistique qui jouait souvent avec
Laurent fracinet ou des choses comme ça
quand je fais
il y avait c'était tous les soirs
c'était quand on était Mazet tout ça
aussi j'aime bien et moi j'adore ça hein
à chaque coup mais j'adorais quoi en
fait bon je suis pas très bon mais
j'adore ça c'est
qui jouait à la belote au Cap d'Agde qui
était parti sans payer ses dettes
et c'était bon c'était medhiar qui a
raconté ça donc on sait jamais c'est
[Rires]
mais carbone ça devrait commencer désolé
à peu près les la position et du coup
ils ont un quart d'heure pour travailler
avec leur second ans donc là le quart
d'heure est quasiment écoulé donc là ça
commence dans les deux prochaines
minutes on va dire ça je pense qu'ils
sont dit 20h bah ça mais ça y est ils
arrivent tu vois donc ça va vraiment
tout doit être bien timé
et après ça va tourner beaucoup plus
vite en fait c'est la pause la plus
longue entre les deux mini match en fait
puisqu'il retire les parties ils ont un
quart d'heure de réflexion maintenant il
y aura plus ce délire là ils vont jouer
leur part première partie il y aura une
petite pause de 5 minutes mais qui est
brève et après ça repart directement là
c'est la pause longue s'ils ont un petit
temps de prépa le petit temps de prépa à
l'ancienne en plus j'aime bien ce moment
là j'aimerais bien qu'il y ait des
petites Cannes des petites cames
secrètes tu sais mais bon avec les
affaires en cours ben forcément c'est
pas très tendance j'aimerais bien voir
ce que les mec je te dis ça serait juste
génial quoi c'est pas les canons quoi
enfin j'ai pas les positions ah ça y est
j'ai les positions mais pas tous ah ça y
est personne n'a qu'à
je pense qu'on va suivre quand même ce
petit match en priorité quand même
personne n'a qu'à qui m'a l'air d'être
le match le match à regarder le gros
derby la revanche de de 45 du Damme 4
qu'il a perdu la tour
t'imagines sauf si on avait une petite
caméra dans dans chaque salle où ils
sont allés préparer et qu'on est les
commentaires en même temps mais on se
régalerait de voir de voir ça tu sais à
une époque où vous allez toujours au
tournoi Amber qui était qui était à Nice
et ben parfois
un petit peu sans avoir le droit dans la
salle un peu VIP et
en fait tous les autres avec tous les
joueurs qui étaient là en fait qui
analysait une position et la porte est
ouverte je suis rentré et en fait est-ce
qu'il y avait du champagne aussi est en
a profité pour boire un coup sûr pas du
tout non non mais en fait tu avais je me
souviens plus qui avait deux joueurs qui
analysé une position un truc genre
cramique qui analysait avec je sais pas
avec un joueur
caryakin un truc comme et en fait avec
tout le monde autour donc les carcelles
les Topalov bon c'était un tournoi tous
les meilleurs joueurs du monde de
l'époque ils arrivent en dessous qui
faisait les 100 pas dans la pièce même
qui a chacun ici
et en fait ils vont chouk faisait les
100 pas dans la pièce et à chaque fois
qu'il revenait au niveau de la pollution
il a regardé
le plafond et repartait marcher il
revenait il y avait des plafond il a
fait deux fois comme ça et quand il est
revenu il a proposé un coup il a tout le
monde l'a regardé ah ouais le génie quoi
et en fait il avait trouvé le coup quoi
juste il va en dessous que j'ai mis bon
les gars H4 H5
on a tout compris H4 H5 est-ce qu'ils
vont faire un tour H3 tours HC c'est
tout machin nul et quoi les débloquer
les cavalière G6 parce que en vrai ce
qui serait possible pour eux c'est de
faire ça ils aiment bien faire le
comment ça s'appelle
le banc cloud
c'est pas très sérieux
la mésaventure avec Raouf mamedov je
pense qu'ils sont pas très bien c'est
quand même un personnage médiatique et
vous savez que vous m'avez d'Off a
abandonné abandonné au teachus day
contre carcennes au bout de un coup un
petit clin d'oeil parce qu'il a estimé
que le coup de 45 qui était le un des
pires coups de la position G5 sur 4
n'était pas respectueux et le joueur
azéri a décidé de mettre fin à la partie
en abandonnant en disant bon si tu me
respectes pas on joue pas et voilà et du
coup c'est déjà assez compliqué cette
période je pense pour 45 qui serait bien
passé de de ce genre de anecdote quoi
encore B5 on aime bien les pions B un
pour libérer fous d'âme etc
nous on avait dit au début que on
aimerait bien un petit coup du style C4
BK
on connaît cette manœuvre un peu du pion
empoisonné qu'on envoie pour aller
chercher le roi qui va mettre du temps à
Rocket si on décide de faire grand rock
donc H4 pourquoi pas mais il y a eu un
choc directement
alors yes on est comme ça on va voir un
peu ce qui se passe on est parti
donc C4 B3 c'est un peu de civil
j'aime bien impec4 alors que tu en
penses mais ça m'a l'air un peu de
timide de la part de Bloom
ouais on voit beaucoup de prise d'espace
mais bon ok
le 6/3 ok
là typiquement ça donnait envie de jouer
à H4 mais on peut pas
on peut pas des fois tout existe on l'a
bien vu
des fois se faire des petits coups plein
de fantaisie
[Musique]
tu vois anglaise tranquille un petit
truc un petit truc ouais une structure
assez tu vois
solide quoi ok bon on verra une partie
on va avoir un peu ce qui se passe dans
les autres parties qui nous manquent
juste pour voir un petit peu les débuts
parce que
ça t'auras
là c'est le moment où c'est flou tu sais
donc du coup
non non j'ai pas besoin
sur classecom j'ai que deux parties
proposées
pour l'instant c'est pas trop trop grave
en plus j'espère qu'ils vont les mettre
rapidement parce que les moments que il
me manque de
[Musique]
mon délire en plus
je vais pas les parties de
ni le saut avec nepo tout ça
donc on va rester sur 45 je pense
c'est super en plus c'est déjà bien
délire ouais la petite caméra avec le
Grand Échiquier
[Musique]
on pourrait peut-être faire ici aussi un
comme dessin que peut-être des
conséquate d'habitude la cavalier C3 là
sera que le 4 cavaliers
[Musique]
de réfléchir ici parce que c'est pas la
position tradi évidemment donc E6
cavaliers
forcément il y a eu la petite prise ici
quand même à côté
je trouve que les deux joueurs
d'ailleurs jouent vite avec la position
elle ressemble déjà plus à rien enfin
B3 à titre perso si tu veux d'habitude
on arrive à suivre là je trouve qu'ils
sont allés très vite pour des décisions
qui me paraissent complexe surtout du
côté de carlossen qui laisse tout le
centre anaka je vois pas trop pourquoi
c'est si facile à juger que c'est bien
de laisser le centre
et donc lui il a compris mais je trouve
que c'est dur comme décision
ça m'embête tu vois sauf j'aimerais pas
me prendre 5 D5 dans la tronche avec les
All Blacks qui arrivent sur ma tronche
quoi ouais c'est clair ça fait ça fait
peur donc peut-être un cavalier T3 qui
peut empêcher le 5
ou en cavalier F3 aussi dans le même
idée
4 attaquer le 5 pardon
et empêcher des cinq je connais plus les
cases 3 d'ailleurs qui paraît normal
et là l'ordinateur il est pas d'accord
hein on voit la petite jauge qui est
qui descend
donc malheureusement on pourrait pas
vous expliquer pourquoi pour l'instant
[Musique]
ça a l'air logique
il faut défendre ce pion des 4 quand
même ça c'est clair
comment est-ce qu'on défend
il y a
donc une décision comme fois 3 aussi qui
amènerait peut-être le pion passé
parce que je pense que la décision c'est
ef3 c'est dur de donner ce foodcash
blanche mais bon maintenant je peux
jouer vraiment aux échecs c'est
intéressant quand même
6 dessins
qui joue un B7 qui menace
[Musique]
si on prend il va y avoir un petit mal
comme ça
très très
qui a l'air très très à l'aise à sa
position enfant en tout cas à la caméra
il a l'air très très tranquille
complètement mais Carlson il se laisse
pas trop intimider quoi parce qu'il
arrive à suivre le rythme en tout cas
pour le moment et la position est juste
délire en quoi il a un monde ouais il
est en mode vas-y
je m'ennuie quoi je me fais chier
j'ai quand même peur de la construction
des 5 à terme je vois pas du tout
pourquoi on laisse un bloc central
important et comment ça s'explique
ça fait peur en pratique quelque part de
fou derrière
j'ai vraiment peur de cette config
comment ça va se continuer
j'ai pas compris
en rêve musical c'est vraiment j'ai
pensé à autre chose mais
ah oui oui je pense en fait c'est pas
une référence musicale
je suis tellement mauvais en rêve
musical que j'ai cru que c'en était une
tu vois non moi ça allait pas du tout
moi c'est par rapport
[Musique]
au plug oui bien sûr c'est ça c'était ça
c'était la c'était la rêve c'était la
rêve c'était la réponse c'était juste
une évidence
alors d'ailleurs Kevin j'en profite vite
là parce que du coup c'est quand même le
dernier minimax
[Musique]
du coup bonsoir madame bonsoir à toi
j'espère que tu vas très bien
car j'ai envie de te voir sur le sur le
chat
en fait on n'a pas le droit à match nul
je pense parce que
si tu dis un il y a beaucoup plus de
chance
c'est pareil sur la gueule je pense donc
on choisit
les parties sont bizarres
plus bonnes photos
[Musique]
[Rires]
et c'était bon ça méritait un clip le
clip associé à l'autre oui E5 de NACA en
tout cas
à 5 c'est vrai mais ça paraît le plus
long à se mettre en place et moins
impactant
bon alors du coup vas-y je te laisse je
te laisse
commencer si tu veux donc je propose
qu'on choisisse un des joueurs soit
Carlsen soit d'accord
moi je peux difficilement choisir d'un
cas tu sais que je suis procrassen toi
tu es chez non mais c'est juste pareil
moi je joue à des jeux de foot ou des
fois je choisis des joueurs que j'aime
pas mais je sais qu'ils sont bons quoi
oui mais moi j'ai rien contre Nakamura
mais juste que j'adore le style de
Carlson
du coup
bah je propose qu'on parie sur un
résultat peut-être un joueur
mais si on parie sur un résultat on n'a
pas le droit au
et parce que on est obligé d'indiquer
à l'avance
et toi 1 1
les gars on fait les petits Paris entre
nous on parie des petits subs pendant ça
après on a quoi déjà on a une hypocrite
la même poule c'est quoi c'est blueboard
fait doser donc je parle en premier
dans tous les cas c'est moi qui ai parlé
j'ai pas vu du tout la partie de bluebom
je te propose de faire
[Musique]
allez je pense que je vais mettre un et
demi sur sur fedo
je suis obligé de dire
NON je vais je vais dire à ma stratégie
maintenant
comme ça quoi qu'il arrive je suis
toujours en vie comment il s'appelle
et ensuite
je te laisse parler où tu veux faire le
premier ou le deuxième point par dis-moi
il faut que je fasse Greta son en
premier
parce que j'ai pu je lâche c'est flouté
donc du coup
allez je dis qu'il se prend 2-0 parce
que nepo il va il va aller hyper vite et
lui il est il est quand même plus lent
donc il se prend il se reprend de zéro
de zéro n'est pas pour toi
on va voir c'est bien joué à la fin on
la connaît celle-là
moi je veux dire du coup
[Musique]
un et demi pour
tant tu penses qu'il va gagner
non
donc Abdou je vais quand même faire un
et demi
donc tu me laisses le 2-0 mais j'ai pas
envie de dire de zéro je vais rester sur
le 1
qui prend pas trop de risques
2-0 c'est quand même dur sur la dernière
ronde qui lui colle un de zéro
c'est possible mais bon on va voir bon
en tout cas c'est parti
donc c'est toujours pas les parties de
de saut et d'abdo ça me bug je peux pas
cliquer dessus
je vais essayer de
refresh la page
voir si je peux les avoir
ah ça y est c'est un problème de
et maintenant tu montes sur quoi j'ai
parié tu sais avec des positions
qui a l'air à peu près standard normal
ici pas de quoi ça l'armée
tout F2
il y a quelques casques qui ont été
laissés mon cavalier il a du mal à aller
en 4
8 très intéressant quand même bluebom
ou j'ai parié sur un et demi pour fedo
parce que fedo c'est un joueur qui calme
il aime bien attaquer il est très malin
il a bien les
cadences rapides c'est un joueur qui a
déjà plus de 2700 Elo donc il est quand
même il va expérience plus fort que plus
pomme donc un demi malin totalement
je me dis bon il va bien encore poser
des problèmes on va aller voir bar en
rouge on va aller voir une seconde on
fait un peu le tour donc la position moi
j'aime bien les Noirs là perso
[Musique]
c'est des problèmes comme ça entre des
joueurs en
les mimiques il y en a certains ça les
rend fou et ça peut ça peut être sujet à
quelques mots et des fois que l'arbitre
intervienne ça peut ça peut être selon
les cas compliqués
alors donc so et alors là je vois la
jauge je suis pas très content mais on
va voir
[Musique]
c'est vraiment très agréable déjà dès le
début pour Wesley sauts on le voit il
prend les cases
et menace H4 food 4 et cavalier 2
on va le montrer
sur un coup comme ça
mais il y a quand même cavalier E2 sur
le h4g
voilà mais on voit en tout cas que les
Noirs ont les casse centrales les cases
noires au fou il est mauvais alors que
la part de fond noir alors quand même
plus forte que la part de souffle
blanche effectivement comme dit Cyril il
a réussi à trouver des fois des
ressources dans des positions un petit
peu difficiles mais là c'est la bien
stable Cyril quand même l'avantage de
partie non moi j'ai en tête surtout la
partie qu'il a arnaqué entre guillemets
contre catharsson
semble-t-il et puis il a complètement
retourné
donc c'était pas non plus mais là il y
avait une partie où tu es très mal c'est
que là et puis
on voit que on a on a quand même la
jauge par exemple on n'a pas mis l'ordi
mais la jauge c'est quand même une
indication forte que non pas les joueurs
donc s'il faut juste être compréhension
c'est quand même plus chaud et Magnus a
pris un gros zappage est-ce qu'on peut
revoir le moment critique ou parce que
là ça c'est emballé je pense que Naka va
prendre une raclée mais
c'était pas si simple je pense de
pousser au centre
oui bien sûr et c'est le E3 de Carlson
qui est très très bien foutu dans cette
position
c'est là qu'il y avait une prise de
décision forte en termes de structure
là tu peux pas jouer 4 parce que tu
perdrais des quatre tu as plus le mat à
cause de pion qui est au milieu en 4
prise cavaler prend
donc faut prendre un couple possible qui
permet de casser la structure du coup
j'ai la paire de fou les cases noires
quand même assez ouvertes et le purin 5
qui est un peu en PLS
en plus avec un rock qui va se faire
très vite sur la colonel comme avec les
5 non je n'aime pas du tout la
production de danois réussi il y a eu F6
et il va pousser le pion jusqu'en A5
pour rester de créer ce peux passer et
c'est quasiment
au final vous voyez que il a menacé un
truc mais au final les caches blanches
sont sont
cavalier 5 cavalier 8 enfin c'est la
quoi c'est bizarre
c'est assez bizarre ce qui nous fait ici
Naka
et
c'est hyper limite après en vrai moi je
pensais un truc peut-être que c'est
débile ce que je veux dire mais
peut-être que il veut perdre
alors pourquoi est-ce que la carte
voudrait perdre
[Musique]
tu penses ouais parce qu'en fait le
premier du groupe je vois contre le
numéro 2 du groupe
c'est peut-être que en perdant et ben il
préfère jouer les pots que jouer à vous
soit torov on ne sait pas en fait
par rapport au style par rapport
peut-être que juste il préfère
il se fait défoncer et je vais très vite
pour l'ego la position est pas si facile
que ça visiblement tu vois si on 645
trouve pas au niveau de la peut-être que
les deux tu vas nous dire peut-être que
les deux veulent
ce serait drôle là on a envie d'une
cavalue 5 quand même si il prend la
cavale de 5
attention au mode Carson calma fais
attention en maths s'il te plaît
en perdant jusqu'à 2e hyper compliqué
hyper compliqué mais je pense que
peut-être du coup il préfère jouer à des
autorov et du coup et enfin on sait pas
en fait mais
honnêtement je pense que les deux
veulent gagner juste pour gagner contre
soit Magnus pour Hikaru soit
hikaro pour Magnus quoi enfin je veux
dire
il y a trop de rivalités pour que tu
enfin je sais pas ton rival même pour
jouer Intel et que tu es pas du tout sur
de gagner en plus bah tu
t'accepterais pas je pense
c'est bizarre quoi parce que bon
[Musique]
tu as l'impression que c'est trop
bizarre quand même franchement
juste ok il y a pas des erreurs mais
ça a l'air d'être plus plus fort comme
ligne
3 si tu manges là je mange là
c'est hyper tendu maintenant parce que
quand tu mangeras en D6 je suis un petit
peu plus tranquille et je peux faire des
tours
effectivement tu montres et du coup
c'est
ouais voilà on est d'accord avec avec
Cyril vu leur ego je pense que c'est
impossible non oui oui mais en fait vu
la vitesse
Baron Rouge
hyper vite alors que c'est hyper chaud
il y avait plein de décision à prendre
plein de calcul je pense que ils
intoxiquent tu sais enfin il s'intoxique
mutuellement enfin surtout Naka
il fait le mec qui maîtrise tout il aime
bien faire ça
donc là la jauge annonce que grâce à il
est un peu moins bien alors qu'il y a
quelques coups il était il était gagnant
selon la joie parce que on va regarder
une tête de bonne position
et là j'ai pas vu cavalier
d'amour
qui semblaient avoir une bonne tête il a
joué ksg-6 après il fallait trouver sur
tout rachis dans F5 il fallait voir que
kd6 qui est en plus comme Naka vient de
faire un peu enfin vient de déconner
puisqu'il a fait la laisser cette
cavalier 8 tu vois bah il se dit ça peut
être complètement foutu quoi il a rien
maîtrisé à ce moment là après il
maîtrise hein mais sur ce moment là il a
pas fait exprès de se retrouver à jouer
kfcailleux il pense et ici en fait
Carcassonne toi il fait la gueule non au
final il fait la gueule il est pas
content
et
il a comme toi
quelque chose d'intéressant aussi un
moment parce que au lieu de cavalier
veut cet échec il disait on pouvait
passer la tour en H3 G3 le fameux reclip
l'ascenseur là c'était assez intéressant
je trouvais ouais pas mal
ça se voit il fait des grosses limites
là de
et du coup qu'est-ce que j'avais à dire
oui bon en fait on a laissé le module
d'ailleurs donc et du coup le module
proposé sur ton couple H3 et du coup
j'ai vu le coup malheureusement barre
rouge il y a dame 4 Supercoupe de
défense de Bordeaux alors c'est pas de
moi malheureusement mais comme je l'ai
vu je suis obligé de te le dire on avait
laissé le module suite à la position
précédente et du coup dans ma carte
c'est une belle une belle tactique de
défense pour essayer de te calmer
justement
un moment il a complètement déconné pas
maîtriser ce qu'il faisait mais au final
ça tenait cette histoire donc son coup
qui va léger si c'était aléatoire
et maintenant en plus il prend en retard
colossalotan contre un joueur comicaru
c'est toujours extrêmement dangereux
d'ailleurs il vient de jouer la Dame des
trois donc là
on disait que peut-être prise et donc
j'ai 6 qui était aussi intéressant et là
il y a quand même la pression sur le
plan G2 c'est pas comment donc il a dû
calculer cette suite
mais on sent que c'est chaud et puis il
faut toujours calculer tour G2 cavaliers
F4 cavalier H3 enfin il y a beaucoup de
lignes à calculer du coup ça doit être
dur pour 45 quand même de tout calculer
ici coller et quand même c'est vrai que
ça quand même ça pose des problèmes
je cherche depuis tout à l'heure je
trouve que c'est extrêmement difficile
cavalier 4
est-ce qu'on peut jouer un coup comme
cavalier C6 c'est bizarre mais bon tu
vas me faire
OK
[Musique]
c'est vraiment des complications
importantes
complet
[Musique]
et
je vais vous mettre la grande came pour
que vous puissiez voir un peu mieux
en tout cas cette partie tient ses
promesses et
il doit se dire Carlson je vois gros
que il se dit punaise Naka il joue comme
comme un clubber comme un streamer et
puis moi je me fais
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est une bonne idée de en fait rend
quelqu'un si on peut jouer deux coups on
est bien
mais
comment on joue cette position c'est pas
facile
dans cette position
prise
[Musique]
et prise F2 tu vois
mais bon oui ça a l'air que c'est pas le
coup très naturel quand même
pour arroser ce serait cool quoi
peut-être juste prise
rock prise de sang et je prends le 5 et
puis et puis on joue quoi peut-être
[Musique]
beaucoup de jeux si tu veux sauf pour la
pièce la chaise j'ai l'impression que
c'est les noirs qui ont encore le jeu
quoi ça le truc
prise et que je joue à 5 mes trucs
peut-être mais je peux peut-être
qui est qui est serein
et qui est d'accueil il est vraiment
très serein
je vais regarder l'ordinateur tu vois ce
qu'il dit
c'est
la réponse les gars
il me regarde reboot le rock je peux le
faire parce que j'ai le droit à côté
c'est la partie ce qu'il a fait j'allais
le faire moi-même
il a rocket et
du coup
prise de sang
c'est le seul coup qui perd pas
immédiatement OK et la position elle est
complètement folle il y a
un peu tout en l'air et le roi blanc
enfin le renard tu vois
je peux avoir du jeu mais
voilà si je joue pas ce rock si je joue
pas
faut prendre
le sac doit perdre en direct
donc en tout cas rock c'était le coup le
coup le coup joué de la partie en fait
il était vert Magnus parce qu'il se
retrouve à perdre une pièce mais même
pour lui c'était difficile de se dire
j'ai assez mais après une fois qu'il va
être dans la position et d'ailleurs
Nakamura la décision F5 qu'il va
sûrement prendre ce que je suis pas sûr
qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres coups
candidats mais après faut 5 faut
continuer la partie et va se rendre
compte que c'est difficile et Magnus va
se rendre compte que c'est difficile
pour son adversaire vraisemblablement
F5 c'est facile à jouer mais après au
prochain coup ma mise à jour il faut 5
je pense
et du coup
en fait maintenant
donc Magnus peut penser qu'il est
vraiment à très bien ou c'est pas encore
si clair mais en tout cas petit à petit
nacard vrai sentir un petit peu les
problèmes il a quand même jouer System
pour hein
si continue à jouer vite comme ça mais
c'est pas simple parce que Rouen il y a
toujours trouvé F2
[Musique]
là il y a une NAS de cavalier F2 tout F2
d'un F3 je pense à la 5 des fois
plus de base donc ça peut rééquilibrer
un petit peu et si je mets le fou
ailleurs ben voir ce qui se passe mais
par exemple sur A5 rouge
à 5 c'est quoi le coup parce que
c'est la partie
F2 et dame G6
est-ce qu'on peut jouer un coup de main
comme cavalier 2 ou pas
[Musique]
sur on pouvait faire cavalier F2 tout
rêve 2 dans F3 mais ABC je pense et là
dedans F3
OK
tu vois mais il y a toujours été d'un F3
et AB6
c'était esthétique mais ça ne marche pas
et puis bah écoute
j'ai tout eu un qui va commencer à être
menacé il y a quand même une pression
c'est encore une partie de haute volley
parce que Magnus s'est trompé un moment
en fait ils sont tous les deux trompés à
un moment mais parce que lors du donc
c'était extrêmement difficile voici
Magnus c’était peut-être quand même
génial ce qu'il a fait avec G6 qui était
très tentant par contre
parce qu'il y avait des cahiers des 5 ou
des 5 qui était un avantage faible assez
facile à voir mais il a cru qu'il
gagnait je pense après elle était très
déçu qu'il avait fait par contre une
fois qu'il était dans la mouise il a
trouvé tous les seuls coups dans la
position qui est impressionnant c'est
que Naka il a vu les choses je pense et
qu'il a joué hyper vite pour mettre la
pression parce que cette position il
doit pas être sûr à 100 % mais il fait
comme si par contre
après c'est parti un peu du bluff aussi
mais la pression au temps mais la
position est clairement pas simple pour
pour les Noirs en vrai en pratique je
préfère presque les blancs en fait parce
que les Blancs le plan est simple il
faut ouvrir la position vers le roi et
les Noirs c'est très compliqué mais au
niveau du temps c'est vrai que
carcassienne est mal géré ce début il
fait surprendre par le cavalier des six
de maca
est-ce qu'on ferait pas une petite
un petit
passage sur les autres chéquiers
rapidement voir ce qui se passe
elle est vraiment tellement bien qu'on y
reviendra on va peut-être voir on va
vite donc là on voit plus bonne qui est
très mal au temps quand on fait de l'OC
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour moi
je rappelle qu'on a des Paris entre nous
[Musique]
bloqué mais j'aurais peut-être pu
en plus
après on sait pas ça peut faire de aussi
[Musique]
c'est bien fait bouger il a 10 minutes
de retard non non allez on va pas
avoir pas déconner elle est très bien
cette position d'ailleurs c'est bien ça
c'est un beau massage
vont arriver sur le stream et voir effet
à côté de Steph
[Musique]
j'ai pas compris
ah c'est beaucoup plus clair moi non
plus j'avais pas compris mais j'ai bien
en tout cas ton explication est
t'inquiète pas c'est pas c'est pas le
sens de mon titre
tu sais que en il y a une époque il y a
un titre qui existe c'est le titre de
quand il y a maître qui cm tu vois et en
fait sur le titre enfin sur le papier en
fait genre ça et ben tu as un petit C tu
vois qui dit que tu es candidats et en
fait pour les pour les filles bah ça
fait woman quand il date en fait ça fait
WC pour les filles et je trouve qui
s'appelle WC ça fait quand même c'est un
peu intéressant
c'est pour le coup c'est vrai alors que
bah prend en fait mettre fut le
séminaire c'est WF maître international
féminin c'est WM
et ou W i m je peux commencer et
c'est WG pour grand maître et pour le
titre candidat c'est WC donc voilà bon
je suis qu'un t'inquiète pas j'ai BK
voilà
salut mousticos c'est le moustique
c'était un moment du coup qu'est-ce
qu'on avait dit pour ce match là
c'est vrai sur le site internet
mais sur le site de la Fédération
française des échecs tu vois WC
tu as WC sur les feuilles de papy enfin
papy c'est le programme c'est le
programme de Paris mort d'arbitre
français donc national mais donc nous en
France on a WC pour quand il va mettre
un féminin mais mais voilà
je t'aime beaucoup mais je vais te
rejeter quand même ton ton petit message
tu comprendras que
ne t'inquiète pas je t'en veux pas
donc
voilà
j'avoue mettre fin mettre le fil c'est
aussi un titre un peu à dire pour te
motiver à passer amis quoi et j'ai
c'est ça c'est du coup tout bientôt il
est bien motivé il va être chaud et ça
nous fait plaisir en tout cas bientôt
passer amis ça sera la posée de ma
carrière en tout cas
on va se retrouver là dessus
bon du coup Abdou il est pas si mal en
fait
[Musique]
il arrive à la tenir mais ce qui est pas
évident quand même mais ok tu vois en
fait il va essayer de virer le cavalier
et d'être pousser le pion c'est pas ça
bien sûr c'est tout à fait jouable
je suis très bien
je t'aime très bien
celle-là
va pas prendre enfin qui va faire il va
perdre au moins une quoi et que celle-là
elle est pas bien mais ok bon bah c'est
logique ici
très bien mais c'est pas non plus encore
trop la folie et là c'est chaud on peut
retourner voir voilà là ça va être
vraiment notre fil rouge hein
vraisemblablement parce que la position
est très très tendue malgré la pièce de
plus pour Nakamura c'est c'est une
position avec le roi au milieu est-ce
que tu es hyper casse gueule est-ce que
tu veux te faire un petit un petit Paris
supplémentaire avec un classement
général
sans compter pour l'instant les
demi-finales juste pour aujourd'hui en
fait par rapport à par rapport à ce
qu'on a à ce qu'on a fait
mais faudrait qu'on ait le
on le fera la pause si tu veux
ce qui s'est passé dans cette partie
parce que là c'est dur à faire en live
on n'a pas tous les scores la partie
qu'on a elle est pas mal
mais
ok on va se le faire j'ai déjà marqué
avant tout en premier chez moi
alors du coup recette
j'adore les paris tout ce qui est Paris
toute ma vie
alors cavalier foot tac tac
lement et ça va être dur pour Marinus
parce que elle est obligé de jouer à
l'instant très instinctif alors que on a
qu'un peu décidément de se poser pour
essayer de trouver le les meilleurs
coups et
en pratique c'est c'est beaucoup plus
facile à jouer pour pour Naka quand même
qu'il y a beaucoup de temps à la pendule
il a quand même l'air d'avoir échangé
quelques pièces
on sent que la tension baisse un petit
peu après il faut trouver quand même des
coups à chaque fois pour les noirs
peut-être est-ce qu'on peut replacer le
roi en F7 bah non parce qu'il y a des
cavaliers E5 qui peuvent arriver donc
c'est pas facile j'aimerais bien me
soulager un petit peu dans cette
position
je n'y arrive pas
exactement marron qui est 5
grosse grosse tension là
c'est le moment clé
en plus il y a une idée aussi après faut
prendre des aides d'un point 7 même dans
B7 ça peut être une menace un jour oui
bien sûr parce que on prend le pion il
va Adam et puis c'est du castes je
prends ça quoi et après j'ai c'est
compliqué en pratique mais bon en
personne avec une multination qui est
très compliqué c'est un peu peur pour
lui en fait c'est juste ça que je te dis
d'ailleurs il faut que je change quand
je glace la rendre 6 j'ai oublié de vous
changer ça les gars
et intervention technique en direct live
et ouais vite c'est bien fait et on
repart là dessus
donc intéressant franchement la pause
hyper intéressante Carson qui est quand
même bien blender encore une fois contre
Dakar
c'est pas la première fois qu'il bloque
dans cet endroit mais la potion reste
quand même hyper compliqué
peut-être améliorer tour G4 peut-être il
faut que faire quelque chose trouver un
coup c'est dur quand même bateau
bravo
ouais en fait je trouvais pas de coups
d'amélioration en fait tout fois par ça
parce que voilà
quand vous savez pas quoi faire vous
améliorez vos pièces et c'est déjà pas
mal c'est clair
hyper important merci beaucoup en tout
cas j'ai le cas pour ton message
ça me fait plaisir aussi d'être là
donc les faces finales demi-finale et
finale ce jour on Samedi et Dimanche et
seront commentés par Blitz stream sur
cette même chaîne
donc demain c'est repos pour pour tout
le monde
et pas ce qui nous sort une citation
célèbre est tes pièces tes pièces tedron
magnifique
il va nous le dire
une 5 minutes dans au prochain coup donc
là on n'a pas en rouge qu'on voit ici
c'est quand même en art de jouer mais on
n'a pas eu tout sur l'échiquier ah oui
oui
donc il y a eu dans ces trois attaque la
tour roi F1 il y a tout en prise et à
toura4 menaces ton rachat il y aura
cavaliste fourchette la tour elle est un
peu piégée
là il y a
je suis mangé par la tour cette tour là
et là du coup cavaler 6 du coup il y a
une fourchette mais puis on prend
j'ai plus
je sais pas pourquoi sur le sur le
discord j'ai plus j'ai plus la position
je suis resté bloqué avant tout G4 tu
sais et il faut que j'actualise c'est
quoi si tu veux je te lève enlève le
partage je te le refais
le stream et je te le renvoie
[Musique]
immédiatement du coup nous on va avoir
un
tu vois ou pas là
c'est morfi ok merci et merci Google
il a rendu la qualité
et aussi dans ma tête intéressante
qui se battent ces pièces de moi
franchement c'est chaud là il prend ici
il défend F2 et ce petit pion qui peut
quand même causer pas mal de ravages
chez les noirs
c'est plutôt pas la Morphy reboot je
sais pas s'il y a une rêve avec ton Alex
mais
c'est pas là
c'est Paul
donc que j'ai 4 j'imagine qu'il faut
manger à 7
mais faire attention qu'il y a qu'un
voyage de qui peut arriver en fait
est-ce que c'est tu vois c'est chaud
cette histoire parce que je vais ici
faut voir mais là de partout j'ai une
dame en vrai c'est un enfer pour les
blancs en calculer tout ça
très très tendu il y a eu un point à 7
c'est la partie
cavalier H2 3
pour jouer avec la pièce de moi mais les
deux pions là haut intéressant
quand même
c'est pas suffisant ou histoire
pas suffisant
mais il y aura des échecs derrière j'ai
trois j'ai l'impression que
il y a toujours un moyen d'attaquer
ok je pense en tout cas enfin j'ai pas
trouvé comment le cavalier oui non non
pas moyen que je te fasse des échecs
comme ça je rampe
c'est compliqué
il est pas content il est pas content du
tout donc il a dû voir un truc
genre juste pour voir en fait parce que
elle avait l'air pas si mal par rapport
à ce qu'on a calculé
tout le temps
là je suis à leur dire
elle donne un chemin mais il répète en
fait
ah non il va sur
[Musique]
il tourne encore il tourne donc du coup
je pense que ce qu'on a vu c'est nul
en tout cas par rapport à l'ordi
et ce qui m'a un super résultat pour
gracile qui a blender dans la partie
je suis bien d'accord avec toi c'est
vraiment des positions tout à fait
folles à l'intérieur dit de déstructuré
mais bon on est complètement d'accord et
c'est vrai qu'avec tout on se régale à
ce niveau là aussi et il y a très peu de
nuls en fait ça qui est aussi génial
comparé au classique ou il y a beaucoup
de théories il y a beaucoup de
connaissances à avoir et du coup c'est
c'est
il y a très peu de nuls c'est un peu
comme le bled ça c'est de partir rapide
la fiche étroite d'un B5 et sûrement
d'un B7 voilà
et apparemment dame c'est 5 ça
l'ordinateur il donnait un avantage noir
mais on comprend pas
ouais Jean-Mi qui ben c'est pareil
donc du coup du coup voilà
alors on voit que a gagné match
sur les chéquier
[Musique]
et
gretharson du coup qui est toujours en
PLS là tout ça avance
ça va être
la souffrance
les yeux fermés surtout de ne pas tu
sais c'est bien destin
des quatre terminaisons
mais bon que personne ne peut pas il
peut pas faire ça
pas me faire chier c'est dur c'est dur
n'est pas une vitesse folle je trouve
que il a un bon style en plus pour ce
genre de truc mais il a pas réussi à
être précis comme il est d'habitude en
jouant hyper vite
je voudrais pas être occupé avec Kevin
ouais mais bon après
un titre comme ça alors qu'on peut
l'acquérir soi-même facilement il va le
faire
il est déjà inventé avant qu'on ouvre ça
c'était bien éloigné à 22,90 là 23 60
c'est quoi
mais bon ok il me reste encore quelques
points à prendre mais
j'avais un hello comme ça 23,72 à chaque
fois que je redescendais à ce et Lola ça
me faisait à chaque fois j'ai fait deux
normes de grand-mère à 23,72 et entre
temps je t'ai remonté 24 30 tu vois hop
je revenais 2312 bam c'était moelleux
quoi le vélo parfait pour pour se
remettre dedans donc tu vas avoir comme
ça tu as ton 22,84
112 je l'ai je l'ai jamais eu j'ai eu 90
record j'ai eu 85 80 79 75
[Musique]
j'avais eu 99 et j'ai perdu 3 ans à
cause de ça c'est Arnaud
salut Arnaud c'est le chef des modaux
chez moi
hello la barre en rouge est-ce que c'est
énorme oui j'ai cinq normes de mètres
marron
[Rires]
j'en ai bien plus que ce qu'il en faut
et du coup ça fait déjà depuis 2016 et
que je me bats en fait j'ai fait la
troisième arme en 2016 donc
ça fait quand même un petit peu de temps
que j'attends mais après en 2016
ça fait quand même
6 ans quoi mais il y a pas eu 6 ans de
covid mais en fait quand je suis passé
quand je suis pas assez excuses mais non
tu m'as fait pas à moi
mais en 2016 j'avais 2342 je crois
exactement après ma normale
donc du coup
en fait
j'ai pas encore le hello pour passer
quoi mais c'est plus tard c'est un peu
plus tard 380 70 80 où là bon basta quoi
donne-moi les points quoi j'en ai marre
quoi
moi je suis un de très très rares titré
à avoir un coefficient 15
parce que tu dois être
pas un jeu depuis très longtemps
j'imagine un bar en rouge tu t'arrêtais
de joke au moment du coup F15 peut-être
en rouge est-ce que je me trompe
c'est impossible
là actuellement ils l'ont vu en fait tu
as été coefficient parce que moi j'ai
moi j'ai connu le coefficient 15 et le
coefficient à l'époque c'était combien
30 quand tu pars c'est feed c'était
commission 30 pendant
30 parties je crois d'ailleurs et après
tu passais que vais sur 15 puis 10
et maintenant c'est 20 et
40 40
c'est beaucoup trop mais bon
pendant cette petite pause que tu peux
tenter un petit un petit refresh sur le
discord de pour voir un bug
ouais ouais maintenant ça bug depuis le
petit depuis tout à l'heure moi je peux
suivre ailleurs
parce que sur le
c'est un peu plus modeste je te mets en
15 FPS ça allait mieux la dernière fois
est-ce que ça va mieux
pour l'instant c'est il faut l'enlever
le remède parce qu'il est il est bloqué
quoi
tu perds enfin super pour l'instant il
est enlevé
[Musique]
on va changer
je te fais un truc ce que ça va mieux
je vais tester un truc
donc non si ça veut dire quoi pardon
raconte nous tout et pour nous dire faut
nous dire bah on a envie de savoir
tournois et donc j'ai fait valider mon
titre de EMI à l'époque Sonic 400
et du coup au Baron Rouge
il a fait valider donc faire valider
normalement c'est bon mais bon
donc
avec un coef 15
mais du coup maintenant
[Musique]
ça doit être
il fallait prouver que l'on était 2004
c'est différent les règles à l'époque
OK
remettre ce battle non mais je crois que
tu confonds avec parce que bah en rouge
je crois qu'on me confond souvent avec
un autre quelque chose rouge un baron
quelque chose ou un parce qu'il me
semble qu'il y a d'ailleurs des
confusions avec lui
c'est pas ma tête le roi tour mais bon
c'était maître je pense que c'est
Mathieu ah c'est marrant fou c'est ça
c'est ça il y a
c'est le
coup
mine de Naka ce qu'il a trouvé pour
tourner c'est pas mal non
ouais donc il tourne un peu
et
[Musique]
dur à jouer
pourquoi il a pas fait roi D8 plutôt
peut-être que je rentre un truc alors
mon idée tu vois c'était sur dame B7
pour apprendre la dame tu vois roi des 8
3 c'est 8 tu vois je me rapprochais du
mais bon faut faire gaffe aussi parce
que j'étais obligé de jouer dans ma tête
maintenant
je crois j'ai 6
pendant que des fois gagner
pour l'instant je reviens dans la game
ouais mais bon c'est non c'est le pour
l'instant dans l'ordre des choses
comme ça donc évidemment
c'est normal que tu je t'avais je t'ai
laissé choisir
j'ai été Seigneur sur les Darson j'ai
pas cours à chaque fois quand même
donc
on connait pas considère que c'est bon
nul ça lui va ce serait génial
il peut toujours rester mais c'est pas
facile mais en tout cas il a pas besoin
c'est clair
qui est mal au temps mais en fait il y a
un bug chez moi parce que du coup ça a
joué hein
encore une fois
dans un bug en fait de cheesecom les
gars ah si ça a joué donc c'est pas si
quelque chose dame D3
[Musique]
je suis un petit peu
attends je vais enlever ça dans l'ordi
[Musique]
peut-être venir avec la dame en F4
essayer de défendre
mais est-ce que quand tu veux pas de
racisme ou F2 c'est compliqué lequel tu
veux perdre tu pourrais manger H5 tu
vois et te dire bon ok ben j'ai encore
de bien passé
quand même mais c'est pas facile ça te
signale en pratique
il va devoir s'arracher pour la gagner
parce que il y a quand même un pion qui
peut avancer on peut se cacher que le
cavalier etc les pions
du coup il a mangé et là je vois il
apprend à H5 ok donc
pas clair mais ok
à zéro chance de perdre cette partie
ça c'est clair
c'est ça
[Musique]
mais bon j'ai quand même un pion au
centre moi aussi et des pions blancs
sont assez lents tu vois et des fois
aussi une heure peuvent essayer de
changer les dames c'est pas clair
l'ordinateur il sera pas trop mais c'est
vrai qu'en pratique je préfère largement
largement les Noirs en tout cas
il y a la pendule qui va jouer un grand
rôle aussi il y a peu de temps pour
Carlsen et la casse un très bon blixer
ouais c'est ça
proposer si Magnus déliception bien sûr
on pourrait proposer un échange de dames
etc mais il faut des circonstances quoi
faut vraiment que mon roi soit très bien
passé avec les Noirs pas facile encore
tout enfin cette position je vous ai mis
la grande la grande caméra pour que vous
puissiez voir bien
le temps dépend du tout ça
Magnus va arriver à essayer de pousser
les pions en tout cas psychos
il a plus rien à faire d'autre que
essayer d'aller c'est un contre-pouvoir
aussi c'est de dire justement tu peux
pas faire ce que tu veux parce que j'ai
ce contre-pouvoir là c'est ça
en faisant ça il essaie d'empêcher aussi
les noirs de pousser leurs pions et de
créer des menaces mais après il peut pas
poster des pions tout seul c'est dur
aussi les pions
il faut les pousser mais faut pas se
faire trouer faut qu'ils avancent avec
une certaine unité regarde F4 voilà
et chacun pousse de son côté et si on va
me prendre des seins qu'il y avait
du pire
donc fourchette et clouage
donc il y a eu droit je crois qui permet
d'enlever le clouage menace le pion et
plus le pur avant plus quand même il y a
de
possibilités de pouvoir trouver un
perpétuel et aussi après Descartes il y
a plus d'échec sur la diagonale donc
après G4 je peux profiter des trois je
rêve d'apprendre lors d'un temps avec
moi mais
moi je me comprends
des quatre
il se passe
peut-être plus précis qui empêche les
échecs et qui attaqué
il y a eu le roi G4 de Magnus
on va essayer de suivre aussi sur la sur
la caméra parce que du coup des fois on
a un peu de délai
avancer il est pas content d'accord pour
une fois la première fois il fait plein
de mimiques donc ça veut pas dire
grand-chose
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on joue
maintenant
et G4 en fait
si un jour il perd l'opium
[Musique]
3 il y a pas de clouage et sur Madame
qui
vient défendre
qui vient défendre F4 et là intéressant
si le cavalier bouge il y aura toujours
l'option ici et là éventuellement
pression chacun de nos jours mes
pressions sur c'est compliqué parce que
G4 en l'air
je pense que c'est vraiment très
difficile pour les deux joueurs de
progresser qu'on va voir une nulle
prochainement sur roisé
[Musique]
quand même ça peut faire la peur
d'un mec sur damastron et échec tu vas
où en fait
pourquoi on prépare roi des deux ce
qu'il y a plein d'échec
roi des 1 tu sais il est venu en E2
personne qui a plus de temps la pendule
à 30
et je vais toujours je place
[Musique]
pas faire n'importe quoi non plus hein
le temps tourne de
Naka ils ont
gagné je peux gagner je peux gagner
à la nulle parce que là il a l'air
d'être fâché
que quel
objet
le matin
ils ont plus de temps tous les deux
avec un incrément à chaque fois de 5
secondes
je rappelle la cadence c'est 5 secondes
chacun
et là il fait chaud
on peut plus commenter c'est le temps
qui va tout décider et là
il y a un clouage sur le cavalier il
peut pas
briller le cavalier
on sent que ça risque de faire un nul
ils vont répéter maintenant
gros sauvetage dans cette partie
franchement
il a déconné un moment mais après
qu'est-ce qu'il a été bon
aussi en plus c'était une grosse partie
en fait non mais les deux
la position elle est hyper compliquée la
position même quand la pièce de 2 mois
ok nul nul signé par les joueurs car
scène qui est rassuré
et encore c'est vraiment un bel
affrontement ouais c'est clair c'est
clair
je suis bien d'accord avec toi mais de
toute façon franchement bah alors trois
parties alors effectivement dans une
partie car en scène a fait une énorme
bêtise mais sinon c'est vraiment pas du
très haut niveau on le sait quand il
s'affrontent mais effectivement c'est
très spectaculaire en fait de bout en
bout il y a pas du tout de théorie qui
qui est un peu plus fastidieuse à
regarder et ce qui est cool les deux
joueurs jouent pour le gain les deux
joueurs veulent se battre ça c'est
vraiment génial quoi complètement baron
belle défense
ils ont bien joué ils sont bien foutus
sur la tronche c'était pas la petite
partie tu sais on disait ils vont
peut-être ceux qui a battu amster of
dans cette dans cette première partie
donc il a réussi à venir à bout
j'ai parié un et demi sur fait de sayefs
j'ai parié un et demi donc là je suis
out et toi tu as parié sur un donc du
coup il faudrait que abdoulah
donc du coup avec la victoire de de saut
ici Ben
et la victoire il a besoin de finir le
travail quoi ouais mais là c'est fini en
fait parce que
si je vous remets le score du du truc
ben dépôt il a 5 saut il a 4 ils ont
chacun à gagner leur partie donc ah non
c'est pas encore fini donc c'est pas
encore fini